taux j'ai envie de dire on va regarder
ça en douceur je vis à vis arriver dans
le chatt évidemment près toutes les
émotions ou hier des douceurs attention
attendez attendez attendez attendez
attendez j'ai le truc qui soufflent le
chaud de fenêtres parce que je vérifiais
voilà en est bon désolé pour l'inception
stream alors j'ai récupéré le chat pour
de bon nombre serait permis de vérifier
au passage que ça marchait j'ai envie de
dire c'était pas plus mal donc ouais
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire on va on
va être tranquille il va pas y avoir
d'envolées lyriques dans les
commentaires j'espère que vous m'en
excuserez mais bon difficile de faire
autrement
difficile de faire autrement jouer je
vais checker un dernier petit truc je
tiens un petit truc je vais bloquer le
son de ce truc là aussi
alors attendez je vais écrire des petits
messages justement salut à lui de big c
là pour le soutien moral
bah écoute merci à merci à toi je
prépare deux trois trucs pour avant de
concerner tu commences de sens et
commencé à 16 heures je laisse un peu
arrivé salut à mozac riddle a donc ça et
et donc attendez donc salut à tous je
vous vois non le chat en a salué ses
choix est-ce que c'est le rush et cheney
est ce que le che cheminer dans le chat
c'est le vrai chez chun et ce serait
abusée si c'est leur s échelonner c'est
abusé parce que je regarde sa chaîne
chaîne excellente l'achète de chez
cheminée mais ça m'étonnerait que ce
soit le vrai nom arrête
si c'est vrai j'ai choisi je suis sur le
cul ça serait franchement amusé nantes
c'est je vais regarder ce serait
vraiment abusé que ce soit le vrai c'est
possible ce soit le vrai non c'est pas
vrai ou c'est le vrai nom je crois pas
non sérieux c'est le vrai chez chun et
non arrête ça no fake
non en effet je crois que c'est vraiment
assez ouf quoi prendre un salut mec
pincer ou photos de te voir ici je
regarde vraiment ont contenu ça me fait
marrer
non mais c'est ouf ça bat sérieux ça me
fait trop plein ça ça fait plaise je
pensais qu'en fait il hier j'avais eu
tous les trucs qui pouvait me faire
plaisir au possible et puis aujourd'hui
je vois se garde en tchat comment tu es
tombé là dessus mec c'est là pour ça
j'ai pris le premier screenshot voir ce
que ça ne t'a appris ça t'as fait ça
hier mec quand il y avait le truc de mvl
ou et vous comment on commente est tombé
sur cette chaîne tu veux dire
aujourd'hui complètement random baïnes
on n'a pas grand monde aujourd'hui hier
hier y avait du monde il y avait
tellement de monde
il y avait tellement de monde c'était
fou c'était fou
tanabe twitch s d'après le premier
scream ouais bah je suis pas sûr tu
tombes sur le meilleur ce crime de
l'année là parce qu'hier c'était c'était
trop épique
hier c'était trop épique je crois qu'on
a fait sept heures de live et derrière
la vidéo de résumer donc c'était
vraiment ouf
et donc là aujourd'hui on va être on va
être on va être en mode tranquille on va
récupérer parce que demain ça reprend
demain on aura la finale
by ces jugements vivre est franchement
franchement on va regarder des arénas
king sûr sur youtube sur ma chaîne
youtube ou un truc comme ça tu seras
moins déçu tu seras pas indécis je sais
pas si ça va être nul honnêtement mais à
mais c'est un petit match comment dire
un petit match ouais aujourd'hui on
commente un petit match ça va être
facile et s'obtient d'ailleurs ça
commençait ça a été super et cyber
elephant voit l'écart en dessous donc du
coup de ladislav artemiev qu'entre os
laisse au chemin vert dans le chat vous
avez des favoris ou pas vous avez des
favoris ou pas les mecs qui pensent
moi j'ai envie d'être pour ladislav à
cause du prénom bref la dilettante et à
l'aise sur la vidéo d'hier soir à 3h du
mat ça se voyait il n'en pouvait plus
quoi ils suer à grosses gouttes et en
tout cas bravo pour toi j'ai cheminé
dans le pur pour tes vidéos ça fait
plaise salua poupine à tort pour être
cité pour vlad ce mec est père de
famille les mecs ce mec est un athlète
c'est à dire qu'il est il est père de
famille quoi ça se voit pas forcément
c'est pour le russe ouais mais c'est fou
quand il ay là il a une tête d'un gamin
de 16 ans est en réalité chez pas il a
quoi il a 21 ans 22 ans il est père de
famille et et il a il a un placard
horrible derrière et wesley so bon vous
le connaissez de toute façon pour la
plupart wade et père de famille il est
père de famille wesley so
il est quoi il est numéro 11 12 mondial
maintenant champion du monde de 960
quand même il avait battu magnus et du
coup on a quoi comme ouverture d un
genre de gambie dame talent fou en b2
qui est pas pas excellent parce qu'il ya
ce conflit là avec avec le pion des
quatre mais il va faire du cd ou quelque
chose comme ça cette structure de pions
la cie tous échange il ajouterait bien à
6000 f et d'oncle artemiev avec les
blancs ils jouent très bien au genre de
structure avec les pions des quatre des
cinq symétrique et il va jouer le bon
fou contre le mauvais faubourg
objectivement il n'y a rien c'est pas
assez pour pour gagner ou faire quoi que
ce soit mais il va un petit peu pressé
après contre certains joueurs je dirais
il pourrait avoir un edge mais mais
contre eux wesley qui est le joueur le
plus solide du cercle avec car yakine ce
genre de position je ne vois pas comment
tu vas gagner du tout eu peu d air même
mais c'est ok à 5 fois ci tu voir du mal
à faire peut-être tu vas laisser la
colonne ne m'en faut faire gaffe de
hockey même si prend la colonne d'eau de
façon tu as la colonne c est le genre si
tu prends il veut quoi il veut dame
reprend et gagne cette colonne malle
arrière tu peux même faire un roi et
fuite
parions qu'il faut prendre à vii j'abuse
la puce j'abuse il ya le pion à vii mais
bon d'ailleurs il a fait prise prise
d'effets ou celle ci souhaite donc ok il
va contrôler la colonne avec le fou donc
il veut tour 8 à 5 en gros et moi et
tours 8 à 5 pour la colonne le il met
les pions sur noir allèles dames et il a
le fou qui contrôle les cases blanches
ma foi avons talent fou détroit qui est
meilleur parce que le pion est sûre
cases noires donc comme le pion central
et sur case noire on va le mettre en
verre avec le fou sur cases blanches
samarie mieux qu'avec fou cate blanchet
et puis on case blanche mais en gros ça
va il va essayer de faire tourner 8 et
évoqué peut-être même des foulées saint
cloud b5 direct ils échangent les les
fous sur foot prend il va prendre 2 à 1
et il veut te fixer le pion à deux avec
la torah vite bien placé tu vas faire
tour ces deux au pire y fait b4y tiens
ici à tous ses pions avec la dame il à
la tour qui attaque à deux donc il est
tranquille et en gros personne va
vraiment pouvoir progresser ça va
continue un peu comme ça avant les
blancs kyushu b1 il veut pas échanger
les fous mais du coup il a fait une
concession le fou qui est quand même
moins bien placé tour 8 / dam des deux
quais probablement pas tour de encore
mais tu peux faire un petit coup de jets
6 pour te protéger le droit te faire une
sortie après enchaîné
avec la tour en e2 écouté ma foi ça va
bien se passer un ça va bien se passer
ça a l'air d'avoir une position
tranquillou c'est quand la finale
annuelle ding c'est à partir de demain
en tout 17 heures vendredi 17h et samedi
dimanche 15h et je lâche une info je
commenterai à 99% sur avec el fahm au
zoo mathieu cornette
donc je ne sais pas quel point à quel
point vous êtes heureux de revoir
mathieu à la place de vlad
non mais ce type est un athlète quand
même mathieu cornette c'est un athlète
non mais c'est cool au monde varie un
peu les profils les personnes et est
quelque part
enfin je sais que mathieu adorent vlad
en plus cela d'abord mathieu donc il ya
une certaine continuité
j'ai envie de dire dans le commentaire
donc c'est cool l'avait retour un qui
est peut-être y va prendre prendre et
faire juger 6,3 g 7 ça doit quand même
suffire ça doit quand même suffire ouais
non mathieu ouais non mathieu ça va être
cool c'est pas le même genre bah c'est
ça qui est intéressant le magic aux tic
je trouve d'ailleurs je sais pas si tu
étais là hier il y avait tellement de
monde dans le chat on a pas on pouvait
pas vraiment réagir avec la ddt avec
4800 on était quand même enfin on a
battu tous les records là hier c'était
c'était incroyable salut tracassant si
la tête c'est spécial artemiev il a un
style j'ai envie de te dire ouais c'est
un joueur de fond de court c'est un
joueur de fond de court et est toujours
là en mode silencieux vrai après ameyar
le live est extraordinaire c'est
honnêtement c'était peut-être un des
meilleurs live un des meilleurs lives de
toujours en réalité en terme d'émotion
c'était vraiment beau ça faisait
longtemps bois on a eu des belles arena
king des beaux trucs mais hier son a
quand même vécu un truc incroyable les
mecs ensemble comme maxime vachier
lagrave qui sur un match comme ça en 12
parties élimine le champion du monde en
titre en +100 lance vraiment lui
marchant dessus
enfin il n'ya pas marcher dessus mais
bon c'était serré machin flamand on est
tellement heureux
non mais bon enfin c'est pour des
moments comme ça qu'on fait autant de
live c'était beau c'était beau
franchement c'était beau c'était beau et
je vous avoue que j'ai été très heureux
aussi à titre personnel pas depuis le
temps qu'on suit les échecs ensemble
maintenant comme je dis souvent se fait
attendre n'a pas d'âme d'âme des uns et
dames crombez un nom mais ce type est
nul non mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
travaux ok mais c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi non mais incroyable
comment tu donnes une pièce comme ça
mais comment tu donnes une pièce comme
ça non mais c'est ridicule
non mais là c'est de la ligue 2 quoi fin
j'ai envie de te dire qui est ce type
fager quand même merde quand même merde
quand même
t'as pas le droit de laisser d'âme des
uns dame prend b1 énormément fins après
après tout ce qu'on a vécu là du coup
filé une pièce comme ça incroyable
incroyable ce coup n'appartient pas à
cette position mais donc je dis ouais ça
me faisait vraiment très plaisir malgré
qu'on n'est pas qu'on n'est pas les
images des riens que vous soyez si si
nombreux à suivre à suivre maxime en
notre compagnie franchement ça
honnêtement même même moi ça m'a touché
aux mêmes émotionnellement ça m'a touché
je me suis plus tard les tontons ils
font plein tu vois en sortie en sortie
srib les diables had sérieux c'est une
communauté de ouf
déjà j'avais dit ça quand j'étais sorti
de la soirée qu'on avait fait à paname
là il ya deux semaines j'avais dis
franchement
[Musique]
franchement communauté de ouf les
tontons sont des génies et est là
d'autant plus j'ai envie de dire je
mangeais diablada prev l'appareil c'est
vraiment une communauté de ouf donc
vraiment vraiment grand merci à vous
parce que ce que malgré le fait voilà
que les portes soient pas toujours
ouvertes etc
on arrive à faire des belles choses et
c'est vraiment très sympa voilà ça fait
très plaisir je voulais lui dire le
droit pas je dis ce que l'on lui en fait
en même temps donc si banal fans fait
une carreaux cannes j'ai envie de te
dire après qu'il ait donné une pièce en
un j'avais payé peut-être plus très
envie d'être pour lui je suis je sais
pas en fait un jour tu as donné une
pièce en un
tu as très mal joué ben pas de chance je
ne suis plus pour toi
par exemple on peut hein enfin j'étais
pour toi mais mérite eu le prénom vlad
fin s'appelle-t-il encore vlad
j'ai envie de te dire ça tactile encore
vlad après après ceux dont deux pièces
en un coup on ne sait pas on ne sait pas
du coup rock et ses trois mages m
3 retenir faite par son cavalier h6 ne
bouge pas c'est pas un athlète ton fou
angers si ce n'est pas un athlète non
plus parce qu'il peut pas enfin il est
un peu bloquée et ok là je te fais f
le truc tu peux apprendre d'eux j'ai tu
te prends fou prend 1,6 quand tu vas
devoir prendre de la cour tu vas te
prendre g5 bon tu vas faire tourcoing f3
vous prenez trois fous pranger zinc dont
il va jouer avec une qualité de moins
mais par défaut passe pas ce genre
sacrifice de qualité tu vois en mode jeu
t'agresse sa crise de qualité puisque je
me suis fait dominer et je l'envoie du
jeu quoi tout en sachant que j'ai 5
n'est peut-être même pas forcé c'est une
possibilité
attends attends qu'est ce que c'est que
ça ouais c'est une alarme c'est une
alarme tellement tellement j'avais peur
de ne pas me réveiller j'ai mis une
alarme en retard par rapport aux à
l'horaire est ce qu'il est bon en bullet
sauverait so so so est bon dans tout les
cadences donc il fait b6 tête g5
quand même moi je suis allé la chercher
cette calotte a pris peut faire du cd
intermédiaire est effectivement mais
quand même tu prends là tu prends la
calèche et tu serre les fesses coiffe un
joueur au bout d'un moment pas mais va
te faire quoi il va te faire f tu fais
quand même g5 qui te prends tu prends il
te fait faux projet 5 et tutorat sur le
fond angers de faim tu joues ça quand
même
bon il le fait exactement c'est ce
qu'ils jouent faux pranger 5 eca et
prend des 5 ha oui non mais ça c'est pas
mal qui est prend des cinq passes qui
joue sur le fait ça à faire quoi safer
pions prend fou prend roi h fuite fou
prend 1,8 donc sur dame prend 1,8 à foug
pranger 5e à prendre c'est un prendre
c'est un prendra huit et latin matériel
assez marrante à trois pièces contre
deux tours mais comme ça joue plus sur
les colonnes qu'autre chose les tours
vont être plus fortes si ça rentre là d'
embrouille fait cavalier cette f4 à
william quatre intermédiaires du hive
affaires f4 et f5 au la fouine all away
ce les sauts en fermant enferma l'aduf
ou g6 au nom mais il est fort auj
l'effort wesley
il n'y a plus du tout pensé il fallait
faire flouer fc est plutôt couvrir avec
le fou et du coup il y aurait eu fou
prend à 8 onces et rentrer dans un truc
un peu hybride de qui ressemble à ce
qu'on edwards mais là il taux de change
de fusil des politesses f4 f5 et il va
contrôler la case h5
non mais c'est extraordinaire il est
vraiment très fort il est vraiment très
très fort wesley n'ont ils vraiment bon
non sérieux il est bon il va il va
retourner en finale l'année dernière je
pas si vous vous rappelez avait perdu en
finale contre na ka dans un match très
serré et là j'ai envie de te dire dès le
début de match irait impressionne
marrant quand même ce joueur qui en 960
en speechless et tout semble beaucoup
plus fort qu'il ne l'en classics comme
s'il y avait un peu perdu quelque chose
en classique parce qu'ils avaient été
très bons on se rappelle steak à l'année
c'est à deux trois ans quand il était
numéro 2 mondial que les gens te disais
que c'était le nouveau be fisher dont
j'ai tout de suite dit sur la chaîne
dont lou vovo wifi charge envie de te
dire bon
laissons lui le temps on a bien vu que
nouvelle fois j'avais raison bon je suis
plus rien mais mais quand même quand
même il impressionne dans ses cadences
que ce soit en speech s ou en 960 ça a
joué devant l'échiquier il avait il a
écrasé il a écrasé magnus wlan usa great
flu penser que son niveau était à peu
près entre 2900 et 3000 en 960 tellement
il est fort donc ouais c'est un joueur
qui quand même impressionne impressionne
dans ces compétitions là et c'est
dommage qu'ils ne puissent pas faire la
même chose lorsqu'il joue en cadence en
cadence classique dans les tournois du
circuit j'ai envie dire professionnels -
artemiev qui a toujours perdu ses
matches en 5 + 1 la cadence 5 + 1 donc
on peut espérer pour lui qu'ils
reviennent graduellement dans le match
mais bon saut c'est pas le genre de
joueur que tu as envie de laisser à + 4
+ 5 après il sait gérer les matches à
wesley alibaba zoo qui je pense que
c'est surtout un problème de mental et
dans viva possible l'impossible possible
possible soit un problème dans villa pas
il n'a pas assez la niaque
en tout cas le championnat du monde 966
la gagner en jouant vraiment d échec
assez impressionnant bon là il veut
empêcher tout rock et à peut-être
fouache quatre noms mais fouache 4 est
ce que c'est si grave peut-être faire
juste un coup de fouet et surtout on
veut un moyen peut-être d'un v8 échec
mais juste tu veux jouer ça en fait
cette finale elle est très simple à
gagner tour c'est un tour c'est 7
reprend à cet imparable et 2 karellis
ont complètement dominé par le fou
d'ailleurs qui lui qui la prend beaucoup
de cases d'un des huit fonds f2i voilà
il va petit à petit 101
un s'incruster s'infiltrait sur la
colonne et tenter de venir gratter un
jour le pion à 7 avec le pion à qui
figerait tout de suite adam dont la
position est complètement gagnante ou
essai devrait pas avoir de problème à
conclure il n'y a pas d'âme pranger 6 en
1 ouais non mais là c'est pas possible
ça fait deux fois qu'ils donnent des
pièces en main quand même donc il ya
déjà un gem i mx effet prendre pour tree
champlain ce live stream d'une
compétition est je sais pas écoute ouais
peut-être les variantes le soul possible
freddy bamboo salut l'ombre de kev
prénom tout cas pour le moment siperian
elephant la artémias fille semble être
en très petite forme
il a quand même filer une pièce en un de
manière assez ridicule dans la première
partie avec une simple double attaque là
la whey c'est un peu denses et un peu
spécial c'est un peu spécial ce que fait
l'éléphant sibérien honnêtement ça joue
pas très bien de son côté après ce sont
des choses qui arrivent peut-être qui
n'est pas en forme il s'est pas voilà il
a il n'a pas mangé de poule et ce matin
il est peut-être mal quoi pourtant je
lui ai bien dit 200 g de haricots verts
poulet arrêt pour mes poulets vladislav
poulet piano trial au delà de national
dans la salle à côté de moi tu pas si
ringarde j'ai pas eu d'écho à lucia qui
quand les gars jouent chez eux comme ça
là comment être sûr qu'ils n'utilisent
pas un ordi pour céder otba il n'y a pas
assez d'argent par rapport à leur
réputation ici tout simplement dans les
matchs de ce pitch n ya jamais eu de
problème et a jamais eu même l'ombre
d'un soupçon
après effectivement s'il y avait plus
d'argent en jeu avec des joueurs d'un
calibre un petit peu moindre il faudrait
prendre d'autres d'autres mesures de
sécurité plus importante
je peux vous dire que pour le
championnat du monde 960 par exemple
pour les derniers tours il y avait des
arbitres qui était chez les gens ça fait
carrément un arbitre derrière quoi pour
s'assurer qu'ils trichent pas donc un
vrai arbitre international coi pas cher
c'était voilà c'est papa par un arbitre
ico plus quoi donc à un moment donné
avant les boeufs il peut il peut y avoir
il peut il peut y avoir ce genre de
choses qui peuvent être mises en place
s'il ya des doutes ou que ou que l'enjeu
est grand comme un titre de champion du
monde on peut on peut avoir un arbitre
qui viennent à domicile pour bien
s'assurer que tout se fasse dans les
règles de l'art la barre dans ton appart
ouais en gros c'est ça c'est ce qui
finit par arriver si si les routes les
si les doutes sont trop importants oui
là c'est les gains les gains sont
ridicules il doit y avoir pour le
vainqueur
celui qui gagne le dernier match il aura
pris 15 mille dollars sur surtout le
grande chaise tours khobar mille dollars
donc pour ces joueurs là vous avez
compris hier que c'est c'est pas des
grosses sommes on vous en a parlé on
vous a un petit peu expliquer tout ça
avec vlad je vais pas forcément revenir
dessus mais c'est pas des sommes qui
sont très importantes pour des joueurs
d'échecs
comment ils sont recrutés les arbitres
bah écoutes je sais pas exactement c'est
pas moi qui je m'occupe pas du tout de
ça tu fais comme moi je fais que des
stream donc a fortiori c'est pas moi qui
prends les décisions dans ces cas-là
mais j'imagine que ce sont des arbitres
d att vrai arbitre quoiqu'il diplômés
qu'est ce que vous appelez triche s'il
vous plaît en fait l'ordinateur jouant
mieux que l'homme si tu as un ordinateur
qui tètent bas il jouera forcément mieux
ton adversaire parce que les logiciels
des chèques sont beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus fort que les joueurs donc
si tu as un logiciel qui tête battue va
forcément battre son adversaire
pourquoi donner sa dame comme ça il a
échangé les dames c'est pas un don c'est
un échange
c'est un échange de dames pourquoi pas
donc cette position les blancs un pion
de plus mais c'est des pions doublé sur
une colonne ouverte
je pense que wes n'est pas loin de là
tenir après faut voir si les blancs
peuvent essayer de faire quelque chose
avec du cavaly c6 ou quoi qui rôderait
avoir avoir de rien mozart idéal les
logiciels sont plus forts mais l'humain
ne reste-t-il pas supérieur malgré tout
dans logiciels sont beaucoup plus forts
que les joueurs il n'y a rien n'y a rien
à dire
on imagine que le pouvoir partir
peut-être vers f3 pour protéger un peu
de et faire une focale sur le cavalier
serait une case à première vue qui
paraît très intéressante puisque c'est
vrai que vous prend des quatre rangs des
quatre tours prend ça va jamais être un
problème à en prendre et à sept et on
mettrait la pression sur le fou décès
douala fait fou j'ai 2 alors peut-être
qu'il n'est pas allé en f3 pour pas se
prendre à eux 5 4
c'est la seule raison que je peux voir
[Musique]
estime la question serait à un cavalier
6,6 ouais c'est pas forcément clair
clair ce que sur cavaliers c6 il a
peut-être tout reprend tout reprend fou
prend foudre en dh 6 par exemple avec
l'idée que sur foot pro f 6 g prend un
f6 les blancs vont jamais progresser on
va mettre le fou en b si c'est le pion
de plus va jamais sentir
donc
en bis l'ordi arrive à calculer dans les
temps au bas largement annie file encore
plus fort en vitesse qu'en partie longue
il voit tellement de coups que plus tu
réduis plus il est fort pour presse il a
fait apprendre b3 lecavalier prendre
tout à l'heure a sûrement pour des
raisons j'aurais pu prendre du cavalier
ou s'y méprendre de à ça permettait
d'ouvrir la tour pour s'en prendre un
peu aux pions c7 et le cavalier le pion
à cette pardon et le cavalier des quatre
est aussi très bien placé donc je peux
comprendre la prise du pion après la
prise du cavalier était aussi jouable
les deux sont jouables quoi donc la
fille qui sait si ce tour d un tour d un
quart de tour prend b3 avec les plantes
a pas l'impression tour des 8,3 et fuite
ouais ça a l'air d'aller pour pour
wesley tour des 8,3 et fuite et arrive
pas à décaler le camarade pour faire
pousser 6 quoi cavale là par exemple
pour prendre les deux fous price is a
lie à tourbes et un échec intermédiaire
à la fée tour des 8,3 et fisc vous ces
six prises et peut-être maintenant
cavalier à 5
ok là jouent dansent tordre la tour
prend b2 fous ces six tours prend à eux
deux tours prend 8,3 g7 et il y avait
deux qui tombe
moyer une pièce de plus mais y aura
trois pions ça doit tenir ça va rentrer
là dedans mais c'est possible de battre
lille à l'ombre de kev parce que lila il
peut enfin il peut même donner notamment
d'un coup il est bizarre lille a enfin
le battre une fois c'est pas un exploit
c'est le battre sur un match en 10
parties qui est un exploit ou même en
quatre parties mais je sais plus quelle
quelle partie j'avais vu de lilas ou un
moment donné il fait un peu al hanak à
quoi ils donnent phaidon un truc en un
coup genre une dame
donc il a peut être un peu fou quoi en
gros la difficulté des blancs c'est le
roi mal placé et les pions la difficulté
des noirs c'est que les blancs 6 active
et qui réussissent avec tour e sata
choper les pions ça peut être dur tu as
tu as fait retour des deux pour pas
laisser le cavalier on vit ici et pas se
faire prendre à vii
ça aurait une certaine logique en tout
cas de faire tour d2 ma foi pourquoi pas
j'ai envie de dire
donc
pour ces deux d'accord il veut attaquer
le fou pour ses sets et maintenant c'est
qu'il ya plus tour c'est cette qui
menacent donc peut-être il va envoyer
les pions f5 et voir ce qui se passe je
pense qu'il va tirer la nulle ou est ce
les f-5 jouer il veut peut-être du roi
et fils cadet courage et 6,6 montres
leroy
là il peut repartir en grève si c'est
avec le roi non là ça va ça tout à fait
pour wesley il fait un échec deux échecs
les deux joueurs qui vont répéter
puisque suroît h3 il voulait
probablement mettre le fou angers 1 pour
faire tout reproche de échec et mat ou
en tout cas le menacer donc deux et demi
1/2 ou est ce les qui a été en petit
difficulté dans cette partie mais qui a
tenu finalement assez tranquillement
donc
wesley qui mène toujours de deux points
qui conserve pour le moment son avantage
sur sur le joueur russe capturé une
application de magnus play et magnus
trainer tu en penses quoi et non
j'utilise passé a plié
j'utilise chasse comme tu vois tu vois
je je fais du jazz comme c'est bien de
chaises comme très bonne application
très bien pour pour s'entraîner tout
cassé quatre vies 17e 2 il va peut-être
mettre le carré y en a trois par la
suite pour s'en prendre à la dame
malappris ans et cinq bien jouer d'un
prince et cinq îles à la petite majorité
allèles d'amin les trois pions à 2 b2c 3
contre b 7 à 6
et de l'autre côté il ya les pions 1e 6e
f7 il va falloir jouer avec 5 f5 et
pousser au centre va bien voir comment
comment ça continue
là on va vouloir jouer comme je vous dis
poussé au centre pour faire jouer sa
majorité et l'autre à pouvoir va vouloir
créer sa majorité de l'eau de pain jouer
au centre la majorité à l roi centrale
et de vouloir jouer la majorité elle
date charmant dans les finales c'est
favorable aux blancs encore que ça lui a
fait ni ça va bien se passer bien se
passer une fin qui est pas à que la
recommence la finale ce sera demain à 17
heures et après samedi et dimanche se
jouera à partir de 15 heures aujourd'hui
repos demain samedi et dimanche oui
exactement
et à partir du 11 donc de mercredi
prochain on aura le tournoi de jérusalem
qui sera le tournoi un petit peu décisif
pour la saison de maxime puisque il
jouera sa place au candidat lors de ce
tournoi c'est l'un l'objectif principal
de sa de sa saison la qualification aux
candidats des candidats qu'on suivra de
toute façon ensemble sur twitch en mars
ce sera du 15 mars au 5 avril
un petit peu plus tard en avril on
devrait avoir notre prochaine soirée
bitstream sur paris attention il y en a
qui l'ont raté j'ai vu dans le tchat
donc on pourra se retrouver devant cette
petite partie insipide au sein j'ai
envie de dire mais peut-être que les
noirs c'est dans ces finales à quand tu
commences à pouvoir pousser sa majorité
en premier prend le sens de côté noir tu
peux être un peu mieux
tu peux même te retrouver un peu mieux
donc faut f3 et après il va y avoir le
cas et qui va bouger et e5 f54 peut-être
caïds et 6 à moins ce qu'ils
réfléchissent à cannes france les 3 et
wii parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya le
clouage ici il peut faire mais il peut
faire tout reprend d un tueur fou prend
cavaliers prend bien donc tout reprend
force et cavaliers prend à melaka value
7 à la fin
alors attendez dans quel ordre ça marche
ce histoire assez bien joué aux karellis
et 6 c'est très bien joué qu'elle prend
d un qui est produite il va revenir en
c3 1 et surtour c1 il ya cave a lieu
deux assez sympa ça et surtout resserré
avec avaient lieu deux échecs
du coup il fait tour b3 donc sur tourbe
étroite au reprend des huit y avait tout
reprend ses trois mais il fait cavalier
des 5 et le truc c qui menacent tour
c'est un math et il empêche cavaliers c6
pascal calais qui couvrent jolie passe
d'armes tactique de la part de dart nf
qui va remporter la partie du coût et
saluons d'ovale dans le tchat
bonsoir à toi césar 30 est ce qu'on peut
déjà dire bonsoir libérerait je pense
qu'à ça et gamers c'est ok merci pour
les live tu penses que pour un débutant
intermédiaire il vaut mieux jouer contre
un ordi de son niveau ou contre un ordi
plus fort qui vous punit à chaque erreur
progresser plus vite
je pense qu'au mieux jouer contre des
gens en fait et ce cartel fait un bon
tacticien oui oui bien sûr bastille
voilà ils sont tous bons en tactique
mais arte mis à fouiller très bon
tactique très il est très complet il a
20 ans il a eu un peu de mal en début de
match ils étaient un peu endormis mais
là on sent qu'il s'est rêvé
et qui là qu'il a repris la plénitude de
ses capacités la voix du roi et fuite
tour b to b 8 machin heureusement mais
pas pour ses huit matches vu le début de
match artemiev on n'aurait pu se poser
des questions mais à tour des quatre et
barry bonds tu as juste faire g63 g7
monter ton roi peut-être faire g63 g7 f
5 5 3 et 6 un jour juste faire gaffe de
passe prendre un tour c'est 6 alors la
lidc sur a3 et veut faire tomber cette
j'imagine messigny veut faire tour hasan
un officier ici cela fait retour à 7
mais le truc c'est qu'on va surtout
racette on va pouvoir faire à 4 tours
prend ainsi ses tours à 4 je vais vous
montrer couple à tour et surtout reprend
b 6 à 2 et tu peut plus arrêter le pion
c'est ce qui va être joué et il va y
avoir un abandon après tour à quatre
voix là et surtout reprend b 6 à 2 et le
pion à filer à dame
parce que j'adore la cape de l'autre qui
joue il peut il peut s'organiser pour le
voir mais après je suis pas sûr que ce
soit ça l'important
pourquoi retenir c'est pas partie du top
10 mondial du vent quoi il lui manque
peut-être de la prépa dans les
ouvertures et puis les invitations dans
les grands tournois
les deux hommes un petit gambie dame
salua slip hoc
tout cas wesley s'il retourne en finale
il pourrait retrouver n'a qu'à son
bourreau de l'année dernière d'avoir
ainsi artemiev se réveille il a été il a
été impressionnant les speech est je
vous rappelle plus des scores exacts des
matches mais il a été très bon donc la
c5 souhaite théorique de se désoler les
gages parents des variantes que je
maîtrise cdd c'est quoi le cinq
puissantes times
tu veux dire quoi ils chouïa en dessous
c'est le temps qui reste à jouer dans
cette cadence si c'est en dessous
ces cinq prises prises on prend des cinq
ce qu'ils hésitent à prendre h4 oeil
prend h4 salle unique il est vrai il va
prendre ses 5 îles reprendre des cinq
noms avec l'idée c'était de faire un
fouet cette dame à 5
du coup il fait changer et sur dame
prend peut-être il cale un tour des huit
ou un fou eu six balles et deux semblent
bons donc fou et deux sur fou j'ai cac
pourrait être intéressant sur iliad a
mené quatre pour jouer sur le clouage
donc il faut trouver mieux ce que tours
8 est une option à qui des rocs des
quatre pour jouer sur le clouage a
peut-être dame b 5 je sais pas mais bon
faut aussi ce même quand même c'est
compliqué il a fait des cartes directes
prises prises et tour des huit alors
tour d un il va vouloir brûler cloud oc
ca est complètement bloqué le pion donc
il faut aussi ce tour d'air
enfin tant d info ici c'est plutôt ya
peut-être une autre idée sur tours
derrière grand roque aussi inquiet
possible autour d un fou au 6b trois
lignes de l'ordi pour ses 8
ouais bon du coup faut mieux faire là
même avec grand roque fou ici ce détroit
pour avoir droit b2 et couvrir les cases
d'entrée rennes on sait qu'alain vrai
pion de +1 d'après le redis c'est pour
ça qu'on avait du mal à voir il a fait
tourner un faute
d'après leurs dires c'est pas moi qui
l'ait trouvée mais faute in early russie
pas ne va pas réussir à colmater la
colonne c est ce sera un problème la
ferme et troyes et tours à ses 8 et il
peut pas qu'il peut pas colmatée la
colonne c est donc il va souffrir
fallait souffrir il va devoir rendre le
pion probablement d'une manière x ou y
venu à beijing en kia ce week-end pour
france-chine il est de pékin
enfin il habite à pékin apparemment il
est français
enfin le fait qu'il veuille chambre et
c'est une victoire de m v elle veut veut
tant à dire que beijing en b français
saluent à fred kara rue salue ton temps
la tournée ici s'est il va avoir pour
cd8 on va doubler on va s'en prendre aux
pions des 4 s'il veut défendre faire
droit aux deux tours cédé 8 3 3 mais mon
tour 800 de penny parce que ça venait à
se bouger quatre échecs
tu vas pas pouvoir garder ton matériel
là c'est sûr il a fait f3 tu vas mettre
leur en f2 et tout liquidé après tour
cédé 8 ça va liquider sa va faire nul et
donc à qui on va pas être amis me 5 + 1
mais en s'approchant du 5 + 1 à la de la
mi-temps du 5 + 1 on devrait avoir un
point d'avancé pour os les sommet mais
artemiev qui a bien un qui a bien serré
le jeu et qui est bien bien revenu dans
le match et bonjour à la fiche est dans
le tchat
merci tony la levure ben écoute on a
fait ce qu'on pouvait avec les
commentaires comme j'ai tout à l'heure
ça fait vraiment plaisir at personnelles
que vous soyez si nombreux à nous suivre
donc voilà je voulais remercier pour ça
donc ça échangeant des cas très bankable
assez égale égal évidemment si la tour
entre en septième c'est pas un problème
parce qu'on mettra la tour en 17 et ça à
faire nul ouais on soyons fiers bas
serait beau d'avoir le même rêve mais en
finale de championnat du monde justement
fait qu'à ma rue des bruyères ou max on
était quatre mille 4800 je crois au max
de max c'est pas mal c'est beau c'est
beau pour des échecs c'est beau
pour des échecs c'est extraordinaire
non666 il a essayé été champion du monde
j'aurais chialer hier un j'aurai fini
par chialer les mecs sains elle je crois
que c'était le record d'audience 1 hier
je crois que c'était un record
d'audience 4800 après c'est avec la
première page et du coup 100 premières
pages on était à 2000 mais soit plus ou
moins être aux alentours des records
d'audience aussi mais bon l'affiché
était belle
l'affiché était belle
bon là ça fait nul sevel gagne au grand
jury ce que sera le plus gros trophée de
sa carrière oui largement ouais merci
traque hassan qui veut partager le bnf
merci tonton
ouais il y avait 300 sur wid youtube est
donc en réalité on a été cinq mille un
moment donné ga taille exacte on a été
cinq mille ce qui est vraiment dans ce
qui est ce qui est ce qui est beaucoup
ce qui est beaucoup il jouera contre 10
grains maïs à être un match sur match
compliqué ouais c'est faisait à mon avis
ce sera un 50 50 1
en tout cas on suivra ça ensemble est-ce
que je faire une intérieure ont la
finale de maxime non on va le laisser en
valais c'est tranquille va laisser
maxime tranquille on fera une interview
une fois qu'il sera au candidat pas s'il
accepte bien évidemment et la finale
c'est à partir de demain donc demain et
après demain on aura les partis
classiques et dimanche les rapides
qu'ils se qualifient faut qu'ils se
qualifient aux candidats faut qu'ils se
qualifier aux candidats alors c'est quoi
le format du jamais vu ça je comprends
pas trop les cinq plus un c'est possible
que quelqu'un me fasse un topo rapid
bike août
il ya trois k dance dance et speech est
5 + 1 3 + 1 1 plus 1 est donc là c'est
la première cadence et 1h30 de jeu 2e
cat en sueur à une heure de jeu et
dernières cadences sur à 30 minutes de
jeu
zurich à 50% de chances de se qualifier
aux candidats je pense plus un mois je
pense plus parce que s'ils s'y fait 6
passes déjà deux tours et qui va en 2000
faut absolument qu'un de ses adversaires
directs gagne le tournoi et ses
adversaires directs sont loin d'être les
favorites des deux chez favori quoi mais
du coup quand bien même quand bien même
il gagnerait contre ding en finale ou
qu'ils perdent ça change pas grand chose
par rapport à son objectif principal
sauf que il sera en confiance donc la
confiance c'est quand même c'est quand
même important quoi c'est un peu d un
peu j'ai un peu des banalités mais mais
bon pas vers les questions sont aussi
assez banal j'ai envie de te dire j'ai
envie de te dire j'ai envie de te dire
voilà mais ouais donc ces exigences et
mieux qui gagne moi le seul truc qui
m'inquiète un peu parce que je suis
quand même de nature inquiète même si
positive mais quand même inquiet surtout
surtout quand il s'agit de la qualif aux
candidats pour maxime
c'est vrai que
il faut pas qu'il est trop d'influx
nerveux dans ces matches dans sa qualif
contre magnus dans les matches à venir
parce que il peut avoir besoin de cet
influx nerveux ou au grand prix de
jérusalem est faut pas qu'il arrive non
plus cramer pour gagner un tournoi
d'exhibition quoi c'est sur pareil c'est
ce truc qui m'inquiète
donc on verra on verra on verra on aura
on aura un élément de réponse déjà à la
sortie du premier tour en espérant
qu'ils passent le premier tour mais on
va voir s'ils passent le premier tour
tranquillement comme il a toujours fait
avant les départage où est ce qu'ils se
retrouvent dans un match galère où il
doit aller jusqu'au jusqu'à l'armageddon
ou quoi pour se qualifier
c'est qu'il l'a nnée français qualifiés
aux candidats de mémoire c'est etienne
bacrot mais ça à l'époque où il y avait
seize joueurs aux candidats donc c'est
un peu différent là maintenant y en a
plus que huit vraiment forcément ça peut
lui faire du bien de s'être qualifié
tout à fait d'accord avec comme my way
quand tu as réussi à éliminer magnus au
départage d'un tournoi forcément ça
donne très ça donne une énorme confiance
alors est-ce que mv elle a cassé une
longue série de victoires de carlos est
non non parce que là la série de
victoires de carl scène c'est en cadence
longue et maxime n'a pas gagné en
cadence longue donc il n'a pas du tout
casser à la série de victoires la
dernière défaite on départage comme ça
ça ça revenait à août quand magnus avait
perdu contre dingli rennes dans les
départage que nous avions suivi en
direct pour la chaîne chaise comme déjà
avec fabien et une victoire
du joueur chinois qui avaient qui
avaient bien dominé le match
d'ailleurs bon le roi noir qui est
toujours un peu faible ce qui enrage 5
qui est dangereux cette dh 6 dames g5
qui peuvent arriver à tout moment pour
aller jouer sur le roi et les noirs qui
essaye de créer un pseudo contre jeu
avec la casse des quatre pour pour un
cavalier et le pion c4 on va voir ce que
ça donne ma foi pour l'instant ça tient
pour les deux on va voir noir qui ont de
bons fouet c'est vrai mais quand même le
roi un peu faible emprise des caprices
des 4 b 3 qui était une option pour
protéger
ils auraient pu éventuellement aussi
penser à être plus actifs de type f4
pour essayer de tout faire péter juhasz
5 qui est complètement ouvrir le roi
mais voilà c'est une autre option peut
être un peu plus gestionnaire un peu
plus dans le style de wesley alors
qu'arras fait un bluff de folie et
prépare en cachette son grand retour en
compte dans quel sens il fait du bluff
je comprends pas trop à quel moment
caruana bluff faille s'est pas mis à mal
jouer
du jour au lendemain caruana qui sera à
mon avis le favori numéro un des
candidats après c'est un tournoi où être
favori au lieu d'avoir
15 % de chances de gagner tata 25% quoi
mais même en étant favorite en dessous
des 50% mais mais je vois pas en quoi
ils bluffent caruana qui est numéro deux
mondial il se laisse pas perdre s'est
pas tu as it unis hikaru bluff en
faisant exprès de mal joué je suis dit
oui peut-être pas j'en sais rien je
crois pas mais oui peut-être mais si tu
me dis donc ouais c'est ce qu'ils
proposent nul mais si tu me dis que
caruana de bluff en étant numéro deux
mondial je suis quand même assez étonné
et la fille premier ex-aequo de la laugh
mène aussi farrell vois pas de quoi ils
bluffent vois pas quel moment en fait il
a il a mal joué cette année pour pour
faire croire à une faiblesse pas
peut-être à une idée est un tournoi en
tête a un truc en tête quoi près le
grand duché source à lui convient pas du
tout à caruana puisqu'il est pas très
bon rapide encore moins blitz il car eux
qualifiés aux candidats non non c'est
qu'on sera ici peut-être en tout ils
bluffent 1 il se qualifie nulle part il
stream
il perd des lots machin et tout est en
fait en fait il est plus fort que jamais
moi je peux vous dire qu'il ya tout qui
va ce liquide et et qu'on se dirige vers
une nouvelle nul et donc on sera
voilà on aura dépassé la mi temps fort
sera à peu près à la mi temps suivant
quand celui-ci la dernière partie de la
cadence à la mi temps de ce 5 + 1 avec
avec un oiseau qui va mener d'un point
et salua cyril qui est pour vous la
balade qui a bien un qui a bien serré le
jeu hein il reste il reste à un point et
c'est vrai qu'il a arrêté de de glisser
donc c'est très bien joué de sa part
il a perdu les deux premières et depuis
humaine il y mène d'un point sur sur les
partis qui sont venus voir et c'est
qu'un peu dégoûté alors on sait pas de
quoi puisque la position doit être juste
nul
ça va répéter pourrissent les trouve une
idée ou pas d'ailleurs
ouais bon il veut jouer tête wesley sur
le fait que sa tour en bessin qu'elle
soit mieux placée puisqu'elle tape entre
guillemets deux pions mais on voit pas
trop comment il va progresser surtout
reprend b5 y aura roi et s'ils sortent
est ce qu'il veut c'est g3 échanger
montée droit angers 4 bon parcours il
s'active donc un petit message du coup à
un maxime sur messenger répondu je me
permets un lait mais qu'aujourd'hui on
ait pécout d'un tranquille
je me permets je me permets mais je
verger le droit aujourd'hui surtout pour
écrire à notre héros national
bon c'est un petit peu bouger plus
surtout que la finale au moment où
j'écrivais elle était complètement
insipide
là ça s'est un petit peu bougé mais bon
ça va être complètement nul quand même
je vois pas pourquoi quelqu'un serait
gagnant à jeudi qui nous a fait rêver
exactement au niveau où on était cinq
milles derrière lui hier prénom c'est
vrai j'aurais jauge de lui dire tu étais
charismatique même beau quelque part du
couple à 2 revient qu'en france écoute
je sais pas donc en réalité les noirs
qui vont faire une technique une défense
philidor face à l'avancée des pions dès
que le roi va passer en rêve 6h ici
mettra les échec par derrière c'est
assez rudimentaire bon c'est
complètement nul et la safer un père
pète et chaque échec et chaque échec
touré 8b 4 mais qu'est-ce qui fait la g
8 tours 8
3 g 7 tours 7
moi j'ai huit tours 7 nuls bonjour à
vous dire que je me suis espagne par
l'ordi et que royal puis de gagner parce
que sur echez trois procès twelve wifi
de gagner complètement n'importe quoi la
fin de la finale non peu importe
non je perds maxime au téléphone juste
comme je les félicite et je lui je lui
écrivais tout notre soutien pour pour
son match pour son match de demain
contre digne on sera là les mecs
après on sera moins nombreux demain avec
avec les parties longues que samedi et
dimanche avec les rapides et quand même
faut 2,5 rock donc ces ouvertures quand
on joue d'ouverture genre larsen canton
avec le fou en v2 on met les pions f4 et
3 pour contrôler la diagonale et l'or
est le quart ayant eu 5 et petit à petit
faire balader le cavalier en d2 et en f3
si on y arrive tout en installant ce
cavalier en un an de 5 un petit peu
comme comme le plan de pillsbury si vous
suivez la chaîne vous avez déjà pu le
voir ce plan de pillsbury ou pas mais
c'est un peu ce même esprit d'idées sauf
que là les noirs vont pas laisser faire
bien évidemment blessés vendredi et
samedi les parties longues et dimanche
les rapides est exactement j'étais dit
autre chose
c'est qu'on parle pas plus de sa
victoire dans les infos besoin qu'on
pourra en parler dans l'équipe quand
même un truc pareil
c'est vrai que ça pourrait paraître dans
les clips au moins qui est un outil un
petit encart le numéro un français bat
le champion du monde
face à ça prouve à quel point on est
largué un personne ne parle de nous voit
tout le monde s'en fout en fait c'est
dommage presse spécialisée sport un
événement pareil pourrait y avoir un mot
quoi ça paraîtrait pas saugrenue là on
passe pour des gens pleutre quoi
personne ne parle de nous ja pleutre la
ffl on a parlé ouais mais la fédération
française de la luz c'est pas cher aux
normes en face à un compte twitter
enfin j'ai envie de te dire bon faut pas
faut pas non plus c'est pas ce pas
l'événement du siècle quoi je sais pas
combien d'heures d'abonnés twitter mais
c'est pas c'est pas un truc majeur c'est
pas l'équipe s'est passé pas eurosport
c'est quand même ça ça reste quand même
un truc assez face à un compte twitter
quoi ces semis confidentielles et même
site un tweet il n'y a rien derrière
323 il faut voir sur facebook ouais mais
c'est pas énorme
en fait en réalité c'est pas énorme le
quotidien avait invité maxime quoi c'est
déjà plus gros il avait parlé de moi
aussi mais sur internet ça reste quand
même ça reste assez confidentiel
tiens par exemple par exemple ou rire
par rapport aux rires jaunes qui avaient
fait une vidéo sur les échecs c'est plus
difficile d'avoir des abos sur youtube
et il ya plusieurs millions d'hab doit
donc c'est non mais c'est ça c'est petit
tu vois son cas sur twitter c'est assez
petit et puis c'est un tweet comme je
vous dise par un article ou quoi par
rapport à un article sur l'équipe ou
ou a eu un mot journal télévisé ou dans
tout le sport c'est complètement
différent
au programme toute raison garder pas
tant mieux qu'il effectua c'est pas pour
dire ouais ça sert à rien ou quoi mais
c'est pour dire c'est ces microscopiques
quoi par rapport à l'impact que ça
devrait avoir ces microscopiques
ça devrait avoir un vrai impact
médiatique un truc pareil donc la partie
qui continue donc ce four b2 qu'est ce
que cauet s'essaye d'éteindre avec ses
pions mais finalement il réussit à faire
le boulot alors qu'à ibb et 4,7 paradoxe
qui veut venir toucher le fouet
cavaliers detroit ce qui va probablement
faire maintenant et s'en débarrasser
probablement au cou au coup suivant
mais t'es pas obligé non plus tu vas te
faire un reportage de 100% ou tuent ou
tu montres les parties ou quad peut
juste faire un truc à titre informatif
montré trois images maxime vachier
lagrave numéro un français bat magnus
carlsen tu montes trois images sont même
pas la partie quoi il se passe quoi sur
dame français 5 c'est quoi le bail c'est
fou prend f6 corrigé 5 même peut-être et
dames cette dame h7 saem attrait ce
genre de choses sur dams et 5 kg 5 soit
est hyper fort tu touche aussi surtout
chef s'est tu touches à 7 tu touche tous
oui et si tu prends pas il valoir tour
h5 au prochain et ça va faire mal
nancy période elephant qui devrait
égaliser là dans cette partie brillant
c'est un super coup
donc
non mais il pourrait y avoir une plus
grosse couverture médiatique des échecs
les mecs à soyons sérieux on nous
propose sourde et saint louis mais ok
mais il se fait autour des 5 le truc
c'est que ton camp des cinq prises des 5
et j'ai pas de matériel en moins je vais
ramener mon carré l'hiver f5 ou l'autre
d'ailleurs et et ajuste égalité
matérielle ici c'est même les blancs qui
ont un pion de plus donc si tu fais pas
d'âme français 5 était juste derrière
donc bien sûr il le fait il fait fou
prend m6 qui est l'autre option davet
fuite il va faire vous prendrez 8 et
maintenant cavalier g51 d'un côté ou de
l'autre
il ya tout qui rentrent quoi et tu vas
menacé d'un match 7 3 a expliqué francis
fourchette banon ça va rentrer tout seul
ici car il jugeait cinq dames f6
admettons dames 8 dames f8 à me 6 échecs
crois je suis damas trois rois g8 damas
sept matches pas ce genre de choses elle
a fait dame prend ici c'est pareil roi
bouche car et ligier simple pour
cavaliers e5 même pour s'ouvrir la
colonne et ça va terminer la partie en
russie faisant exister que largement
plus médiatisé méritoire régionaux
corrige mois kevin si je me trompe
ouais tu te trompes en fait par exemple
quand il y avait la coupe du monde
d'échecs en russie et que c'est radjabov
qui a gagné il ya juste eu un tout petit
encart dans le journal
donc oui c'est plus médiatisé mais tout
le monde s'en fout honnêtement le truc
qui est passé à la télé armageddon ils
ont fait ils ont fait de tournoi et puis
l'on commencé à voir flou ils ont
parfait et c'était du bon c'était une
belle tentative mais ça va pas trop trop
fonctionné et mise à part quand c'est un
joueur russe qui gagne uta où tu as
quand même un petit truc sympa sinon
sinon ça va pas plus loin
alors oui par rapport à la france
évidemment c'est plus médiatisée parce
qu'en france c'est quand même ultra non
médiatisé mais c'est pas non plus au
niveau d'avoir des émissions télé ou que
les gens sachent vraiment ce qui se
passe pas
mais il pourrait être mis un peu plus en
avant que ça aurait au moins avoir un
petit truc informatif là ce serait pas
mal
donc c'était une sicilienne time and off
et blanc font damas trois ils vont
vouloir pour être éventuellement le pion
aux cinq et ils menacent si si pour le
moment puis on prend puis on prend
cavaliers prend qu'il prend et dame
prend donc un coup logique serait fou et
7 pour couvrir la colonne et là tu peut
être eu cinq cavaliers 17 et dames g3
toute l'idée de ta meuf 3 comme ça tu as
passé la dame tu protèges champions et
tu t'en mets une petite sueur sur le
pion g7 qui se retrouvent à attaquer
donc donc donc
tam est roi il va y avoir du s5
en fait c'est de jouer
lorsqu'on sent noailles saucisses effet
il s'est fait égaliser quand même après
un début de match catastrophique pour
pour artemiev ça se passe mieux
combien convient au score le score il
est à côté des noms trois et demi à
trois et demi ça lui arrive coup 444 est
ce que fout prend 1,5 c'est un coup ici
d'un champion prend dame c7 est ce qu'il
ya quelque chose éventuellement tir a
touché le fou qu'un genre de dames eu
deux cd il ya pas moyen de mettre plus
de pression
et y'aura faut aussi sot prochain donc
non même si c'est tentant à première vue
on peut pas sacrifier donc fou j'ai 3
mai sur flu g3 peut-être un truc pénible
c'est fou j'ai quatre la seule casse
pour la dame c3 et des cas de fourchette
donc il va devoir mettre le fou autre
part il a mis angers 5
et quand même des quatre alors direct
avec l'idée sur cavaliers deux fous j'ai
quatre dames g3 bon ça va encore et il a
mis le cavalier en a quatre
donc
peut-être b3 qui avait deux cas et c'est
4 peut être une idée il a joué avec ses
3 et pour casser le centre aussi
possible donc sur fion prend le truc
c'est qu'il jouera cavaliers prend il
mettra la pression sur ses 6 qui sera un
pion à rire et avec une bonne structure
pour les blancs et donc là qui font tour
des huit il renforce le pion des 4 es
sûr puis emprunter ou probablement
reprendre même de la tour
donc vous allez me dire c'est la même
structure de pions mais du coup ils
jouent un peu l'activité et les blancs
qui ont joué b3 ok on arrive à ramener
le four en d2 probablement vous prendre
d'ailleurs et tour c1 mais bon gras du
fou j'ai 100 m haies tour ces 2èmes et
puis on prend après on se sépare et fou
d2 paraît plus plus solide
donc
il ya une énorme différence de niveau
quand il ya 100 places de classement qui
les sépare nom dark à bergues ouais
ouais c'est beaucoup 100 places donc
wife d2 qui a largement une certaine
logique et la tour qui va partir verser
un
il va essayer de jouer sur la colonne
c'est wesley so de s'en prendre aux
pions c6 salut à simon kcr salut à toi à
retenir c'est prometteur ben écoute oui
mais il a fait une mauvaise année cette
année donc à voir comment il se remet ce
que est ce que c'est juste une mauvaise
année dès l'an prochain il va il va
reprendre sa marche en avant ou est-ce
qu'il va il va il va il va se tasser
entre guillemets ça on aura la réponse
que que fin 2020 par prénom il m'aurait
donné que j'exagère un peu mais il fait
une mauvaise fin d'année
cette première qui avait deux quais c4
et s'en prendre aux pions aux 5
je pense qu'il y avait deux quais c4
maintenant finalement finalement après
voilà pas pris un très très long temps
où on a voulu jouer ça il fini par
pouvoir le faire parce que ça va pas du
tout oulala mieux comme ça la petite
lampe eco plus est allumé non mais déjà
c'est avec les échecs qui fait des
grosses audiences sur tweets shirts et
sait déjà c'est déjà une bien belle une
belle mise en avant quand même les gars
faudrait qu'on réussisse à renouveler ça
mais bon c'est vrai que si tu as un
petit peu d'exposition médiatique ou
quoi c'est bien aussi quand même un
petit peu tu restes en parler un petit
peu à la télé une fois temps en temps
quand il se passe quelque chose de
vraiment gros ça pourrait quand même
aidé quand même un petit peu et ses
quatre tours des catadores gens qui
décident artémias de filer la caboche
qui va être prise probablement pour pas
perdre 5 et wesley qui insiste toute
façon la tourelle va pas s'envoler
circulent il prendra le pion et donc il
insiste sur le pion aux 5 avant de
prendre la call of c'est bien joué de la
part de wesley qui a isolé les pions à 6
c 5 5 qui reste faible parce que pas
être aidé par un pion et wesley qui aura
mis la pression à fond sur cinq
mais maintenant il peut prendre en d4
éventuellement
parce que j'aurais fait comme ses
détours à ses seins qui avait peut-être
un jour en c5 ou quoi mais faut pas
avoir peur de son ombre donc
celle à louga coup je m'en aille sur les
commentaires de ac en scène commence à
kevin ba écoute ça a toujours bien mais
pourquoi es tu parti voir les
commentaires de ac en scène c'est un peu
la question qu'on se pose pourquoi il
est tour des six qu'est-ce que faire sur
tourner ici s'il veut prendre prendre et
je voulais vous c4 sûrement quand je
vous cache pas que moi je l'aurais pris
7 calloc'h 1 mais bon il y aura laissé
il insiste sur le fait que si la sla
calloc'h la structure de pions va
changer il jouera il pourrait essayer de
tenter la nulle
bon finalement il à rentrer il faut
attendre sept pour jouer aux échecs
c'est un qui joue c'est véridique que
c'est un cliché ou de soya
c'est un gros clichés
donc le tour dames chez tmg 4 et b6 mais
j'ai pas pris les palets prendre cette
calage quand même fait comprendre que
les pions reste faible et que ça va te
partout mais quand même donc maintenant
il file la pièce ah oui non il lui
filent pas du tout sûr pions pranger
katia tour g6 parce qu'il ya plus fous
ces quatre donc le pion à vii n'est plus
cloud et toutes à l'arrêt que vous ces 4
kg ont été clouées maintenant il l'est
plus donc ils filent pas du tout la
pièce bien au contraire
après attention le fou peut se faire
enfermer menace fou j'ai quatre
peut-être enfilade l'impression ques les
a trop voulu trop voulu jouer au malin à
presque 15 secondes à cyber elephant
donc
autour des 5 fu g4 da match 4 non mais
il s'est complètement raté wesley
bon après il reste plus que quelques
secondes à cyber elephant
alors est ce que vlad va la gagner ou
pas là il ya une menace de fou g5 quand
même et sur pied on prend un f4 il ya
peut-être un petit fou eu deux rois
chefs trois matches toujours élégant où
elle sait qu'il ya 25 secondes qui doit
se mordre les doigts de ne pas avoir
pris la qualité tout à l'heure en d4
food et de jouer pour empêcher ou g5
plus que cinq secondes du côté du joueur
sibérien fou aussi ce qui menace ou
prend des cinq fours en f4 intermédiaire
fu panda ya puis on prend des 5 et le
clouage sur la colonne il l'a pas vu et
artemiev qui craquent artemiev qui
craquent artemiev qui maintenant une
position complètement perdante
un petit coup de fou de recul deux fois
attention pas [ __ ] huayra tout reprend
en g3 mesdames du coup sauve la dame
remets un clouage et là on va pouvoir
rentrer le fou en e3 et maintenant il va
falloir peut-être faire un dam des trois
dames des cinq histoires d'un peut
éclaircir le jeu non il part avec damas
5 eca rallye prend 1,5 c'est bien joué
il avait tout prévu il va reprendre en 5
et surpris on prend trois dames prend
1,3 y'a quoi il ya deux pions de plus
pour les blancs un roi en sécurité à
mettre la dame en c4 il attaque le pion
ces cinq peut-être d'armes français cinq
ans il remet un petit échec et h4 et il
va la gagner tranquillement un nouvel
échec et être d'une tour qui pourrait
montant des cinq ans il prend le pion
dame f5 peut-être la tour qui arrive en
17 ans il refait dante 5 d'amd 8 oui
voilà c'est bien joué ils échangent des
dames et il arrive dans cette finale
avec trois pions contre un qui va
réussir à gagner tranquillement met une
tour sur la sixième on va monter f3 j'ai
4 h 5 pour monter la structure
voilà très tranquille il al'avantage à
la pendule
il doit enchaîner les coups et faire
attention à ces deux pas se prendre à un
moment 1
un prêt move désespéré permettant à son
adversaire éventuellement sur un coup
tempo de lui prendre du matériel dont
qui monte il monte il monte tranquille
f4 3,5 mais maintenant tours 8
e-menaces il menaçait après un coup de
tours j'ai six tours à je suis tu m'as
tu es maintenant après tant aux
attentions papillon pranger 5e répat
mayroy pranger savent bien jouer tout
recettes aux prochains essais gagner ou
wesley qui a repris qui a repris les
devants et qui n'avait pas gagné depuis
bien longtemps il avait mené 2 0 et ça
faisait une petite demi douzaine de
partis qu'il n'avait pas acquis et plus
pris les points donc donc donc voilà la
première page but vide
bien sûr bien sûr air chose qui est
savait donc
donc avec la tour en 1 1 alors c'est
quoi comme ouverture j'ai un peu raté
l'ouverture en naissant de récupérer le
chat couturier jeu que j'ai commencé à
apprendre à jouer aux échecs sur chelsea
environ 2 3 jours pour le coup j'aime
plutôt bien mais c'est assez compliqué
de gagner ça va venir
good soldier bonjour à car peut-on voir
le live et l us dingli rennes demain à
17 heures wasp eur82 donc
phoebé si ce genre de position un peu
peut-être contre-intuitif d'un côté les
noirs ont le centre mais d'un autre côté
les blancs
bah ils veulent contre-attaqué senti un
peu la case f5 pour le cavalier il ya un
peu le plan des cinq le pion aux 5 bon
on va voir si je pouvais pas voir le vel
éclater les chinois ce week end mais je
suis de tout coeur avec lui ben pourquoi
qu'est ce tu fais c'est ta femme qui
t'empêche cyril c'est encore une
histoire comme ça donc
donc dans donc fois fuite
we can marché de noël à strasbourg tu
bosses du coup ça doit être jolie sage a
envie de le faire une fois dans ma vie
n'est quand même pas de transport âgé de
prendre la voiture
as tu vas voir tu bosses pas ouais mais
tu vas les deux jours du coup elle
marchait de colmar est pas mal et j'en
ai entendu parler du marché de colmar
long de 2 km mais le marché de noël à
strasbourg j'ai très envie de le faire
une fois dans ma vie
- la position est très compliqué en
général j'ai toujours l'impression que
les blancs sont mieux mais mais il faut
calculer sur l'impression que tu ouvres
kloet a fait b6 et que tu as le four b3
qui est bien placé mais ça veut rien
dire par exemple le redis la joie sont
évalués préfère les noirs moi je pense
que les blancs vont mieux s'en tirer
il va y avoir des cavaliers g5 pénible
qui peuvent arriver dans certaines
variantes pour taper af set et j'ai
vraiment l'impression que le coupé ici
c'est un peu dans le vide et que les
blancs pourront mieux développer leur
[ __ ] cases noires le four b3 aussi
supérieur aux fous au foie fuites donc
moi je préférais les blancs
après faut calculer qui prend prend
prend et cavaliers c'est ça ouais mais
bon j'avais pas vu un truc et c'est ça
le redis adore et je comprends pourquoi
il vient toucher le fou et il vient
toucher le cavalier en même temps donc
très bien joué de la part de wesley
peut-être c'est un coup comme des six
pour faire cavalier cet échec mais sur
des six comprend car elle les prend
c'est le coût de leurs 10 mai une
certaine logique passé plus que trois
des six a un coût que j'aurais à auquel
j'aurais pensé très rapidement fait ce
que vous prend cavaliers prend moins tu
débarrasse d'un fou est ici prend pas tu
fait cavalier 7 et y'aura f7 en prison
il a pris des quatre c'est logique aussi
il reprend b3 le va prendre en d5 bon il
ya la paire de fou il va y avoir du c5
fou bessette qui arrive ça doit pas être
qatar encore
bon je préfère quand même les noirs du
coup la paire de fou la position est
ouverte
ça c'est plutôt une bonne et une bonne
nouvelle pour wesley il ya combien il
reste treize minutes de temps à jouer
donc normalement cette partie va se
finir et si l'autre du rhin peut il
reste deux parties dans la cadence si un
point d'écart pour wesley
c'est faux faux faux et ce qu'il essaie
vraiment de comme on l'a vu dans les
stats artemiev à un petit peu de mal en
5 + 1 il a toujours été menés à la
sortie du 5 plus simple pour remonter en
3 + 1 et en bulles est donc on
recommande quand même aux joueurs
sibérien de prendre les devants
maintenant parce que ils pourraient le
regretter
s'ils n'y arrivent pas donc à fait fou
des deux ces cinq prises prise aux
américains parce que le civam pourrait
revenir les cars et les f-5 dame 17 mai
qu'a rédigé 3 3 il revient là la dame va
aller en f1 et il va jouer
éventuellement pour tout reprend à 7
je sais qu'un jour des 1481 et l'eau en
ce moment et je retrouvais j'ai retrouvé
le niveau que j'avais il ya un moment
mais s'est dit fier d'avoir le déclic
pourrait me faire avancer ni à élire
demande quel choupi bah écoute travail
mais après l' approche avec chaque
personne est assez individuel je courais
ce qu'il soit surtout reprend à 7
parce qu'il n'ya pas fou pour un f3 d'un
point de la carélie ses huit attaques la
tour suivi tout premiers froids et dame
prend des deux d'accord d'accord donc
bien joué de la part de wesley
sibérienne elephant qui est mal autant
quand même il double les pions dame b
700 prend aux pions f3 c'est bien joué
de la part de l'américain mais larrouy
c'est pas si idiot un petit niveau fait
c'est une ouverture qui est vraiment
difficile à réfuter pour des joueurs en
dessous de 14 115 100 je suis lâché des
appareils comme traille va faire un peu
d'exercice tactique en plus y'a t'il
inscrire après le match ce soir et
n'installe chèque
parfois je me repose un petit peu un
petit peu quand même un petit peu un peu
genre peuvent économiser puisque la sava
stream sera stream vendredi samedi
dimanche donc demain après demain
dimanche puis savard stries mardi avec
le match probablement s'est pas encore
sûr mais les pommiers à china cas et
après ça va stream non-stop tous les
jours jusqu'au 23 décembre
et après ça va ce rythme le 26 27 28 29
et 30 décembre pour pourquoi pour le
championnat du monde rapide et beats qui
sera là encore couverts par thiès comme
ça qu'on couvre à peu près tous la sfio
là on arrive à un niveau de couverture
des tournois c'est un rêve si tu veux
aller seul sur l'estrie montréal je cède
à rift heures mais a cessé le cordonnier
qui s'est pas de chaussures quoi je sais
pas j'ai plus le temps de stream et sur
ma chaîne c'est une catastrophe
le seul truc que je réussis à faire
c'est à sauver et en plus y aura plus de
il y aura pas d'aréna en janvier février
mars avril c'est la rs à prendre un
calendrier beaucoup plus light en
janvier février
mais c'est vrai qu'on a réussi à faire
avec pièces comme cette année un des
objectifs que j'avais fixé en 2000 en
2017 c'est d'arriver à vraiment à faire
un vrai suivi des échecs internationaux
avec avec un mélange
de replays de pas de replays de vidéos
d'analystes donc la finale va sûrement
donner nul mais avant un truc comme ça
il faut faire gaffe de pas se faire
enfermer le roi salma mais ça nous fait
rire je vois pas pourquoi ce serait pas
nul n'y a plus à ses pions sur
l'échiquier non plus je vois pas enfin
il va essayer d'aller prendre h3 et
ouvrages 3 je pense et je vois pas dans
quel monde ça fait pas nul à il remarqua
le temps il ya plus de dix secondes pour
aimer quand même donc rester un objectif
de pouvoir faire et le et les résumés de
parties de haut niveau et les directs
caen est plus ou moins réussi à faire
cela n'est finalement qu'en cas de score
la partie d'andré les jolies ce coup
qu'a réussi dans la partie d'un land un
crâne ikran kramnik ouais c'est des
images qui manquent mais d'un autre côté
j'ai compris a longtemps et nkt a qu'à
voir
[Musique]
que faire le commentaire officiel
c'était quasi impossible parce que moi
je suis quelqu'un qui aime bien quand ça
marche à la performance à la compétence
le reste ça me saoule en fait et donc
donc je me suis fait une raison en fait
c'est donc je me suis fait une raison
pas les images pas les images suis enfin
tant pis tant pis on va pas s'embêter
avec ça on s'affaire perpète wesley qui
a pas voulu tenter c'est vrai qu'il
était plutôt en difficulté et donc sept
minutes 44 une petite caro cannes pour
finir variante d'avançon a déjà vu dans
le match et wesley qui était un petit
peu mieux au final
ouais c'est vrai qu'ils étaient mieux
avec les blancs si je me rappelle bien
et donc oui non si l'on rappelle bien
orange open qui a et b 3 à 4 cette fois
ci le laissent pas mettre le pion à 5
il va sûrement jouer avec ses 4 avec les
blancs tôt ou tard et dont ques les plus
sains
il va quand même fort qu'il fasse gaffe
ouais c'est bien les commentaires
championnat de france ouai on avait fait
des belles audiences aussi c'était cool
y avait du monde et tous avaient permis
de deux fils et un peu de visibilité au
championnat de france donc c'est plutôt
bien
est ce qu'on aura plate pour commenter
ding nv holding non ce sera mathieu
cornette
après hier ça aussi permis de donner de
la visibilité aux grandes chaînes sourds
donc c'est aussi pas mal
quoi qu'il en soit tout ce qui est des
échecs nous fait plaisir
de toute façon comme je les dis je suis
moins - mois embêté par sa cave en fait
j'y pense plus trop tu vois je m'en fous
est ce que je me demande est ce qu'on
peut vouloir jouer c'est un truc un peu
genre ces cinq dames et un daf ou prend
assez incohérent pour aller bouffer le
pion mais le problème je pense sur
damien c'est que marc est sûre jca-t et
cavaliers h4 encore bon à voir la fasch
4g 4 qui avait lieu un foyer du coup il
avait plu car et les h4 mais peut-être
qu'il veut faire qui est des trois
cavaliers f4 maintenant il ya fou prend
g4 aussi qui rôde
du coup parce qu'il n'a pas protégé le
pion
on va voir on va voir position en tout
cas et passionnante peut aussi prendre
en d5 intermédiaires et pranger 4 après
il peut prendre qui prendra ici se prend
des fils et j'ai trois ans qu'il veut
jouer pour fou et 4 et cavaliers des
trois cavaliers eux cinq ils veulent
jouer la case de 5
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant
c'est les quarts ou les demi sel et 2 me
relis chat c'est les 2 me et donc avec
l'ex finaliste j'ai envie de dire wesley
so on propose cavaliers gysi soit kg 6
logique mais quelle g6 peut-être qu'on
va faire du cahier g2 du coup et
cavaliers f4 échanger ses cavaliers
jouer fouet f4 est pour et pour la case
5 de nouveaux genres h5 cas relief 4 ce
pas clair comme position mais non on
comme une belle masse de pièces allaient
droit mais d'un autre côté du quai qui
peut arriver ans et cinq pions à 5 non
c'est intéressant des six france 4 qui a
eu des cinq d'accord mais quelle idée 3
maintenant pour jouer cavalier e 5 et
d'un me 2 pourquoi pas 100 prend un peu
aux pions de 6
cav a lieu quatre d'accord il s'en prend
aux fous peut-être qu'il y des trois
maintenant quand même un jour pour faut
quand même revenir avec ce cavalli qui
est mal placé libérer la tour visé les
cases toutes les cases noires un peu
affaibli vont kg 2 ct l'autre l'autre
manière de jouer
pourquoi pas on a parlé aussi et l'autre
demie a déjà eu lieu dans l'autre demie
ce sera nepomniachi contre nakamura la
caf s'est qualifiée hier aux dépens de
duda naka impressionnant le seul qui
avait mis en danger l'année dernière
c'était ouest gso donc ma foi vue ques
les sauts ça a l'air d'être un match
équilibré contre artemiev dans les deux
cas
l'adversaire de naka rang final 6
qualifie sera dangereux on voit ouest et
très focus très concentré il reste 3
minutes 30 dans la cadence donc ça
devrait être la dernière partie de 5 + 1
qui prend des deux prend des deux
c'était écrit écrit à l'avant sans le
savais que ça allait arriver
j'ai envie de vous dire on n'a pas été
on n'a pas été surpris
donc comment est-ce qu'il va continuer
avec les noirs il a mis la dame en f 7
et peut-être maintenant cavalli qui
pourraient rejaillir verser 5 peut-être
faut faire gaffe abc ce qui était 3h fo
prend des quatre cafés touré feu en et b
ci soit il veut il veut empêcher à cary
lycée 5 à tour un tour deux tours 1
il va venir se placer sur la colonne
contre le pion au 6 mai qui est bien
blindé par le fou position intéressante
tout re 1,3 je suis tisbar way la
position est vraiment équilibré
compliqué je pense je préférais la jouer
avec les blancs perso alors les petites
cases la don camillo 3 il veut supprimer
le cavalier pour s'en prendre aux pions
aux pions eu six ou peut-être faire
cavalier prend est rentré sur la colonne
récent de la part de wesley qui se
placent bien dans cette partie et qui
obtient une posture mon navire
intéressante et noir qui ont beaucoup
avancer les pions
jusqu'à maintenant et qui vont devoir
j'ai envie de dire les sofas sauvegarder
les cases en fait ils ont fait un truc
qu'on peut appeler parfois over extend
prendre trop d espace et du coup on se
retrouve avec de l'espace avait pensé un
petit peu comme si au foot vous avancez
3 avec vos joueurs
lorsque vous perdez le ballon en fait il
ya des attaquants qui part dans le dos
voilà c'est un petit peu là le même
esprit la ligne de hors jeu est très
très avancé côté noir et donc on peut se
faire prendre par derrière
il prend et 25 du ku'damm prend c'est
pour ça qu'il a fait tourner ici c'était
pour protéger le pion aux 6es maintenant
peut-être tour eu quatre dames eux deux
pour venir insisté sur sur les pions sur
cases blanches fou des trois peut être
une option aussi d'ailleurs pour chasser
la dame
ce carré y est mal placé mais il protège
des quatre dons qui remplit quand même
un boulot on veut pas laisser fou prend
des quatre qui s'en prendraient aux
pions à f2 donc il a fait fou des trois
dames 7 et peut-être fou bien pour faire
du dam c2 et sans prendre un petit peu
aux cases blanches la case h7 québec a
donc qui couvre les cases blanches il
évite que les blancs d'oeufs puis se
mettre en batterie dame e3 on veut faire
la batterie en leucate ce qui
permettrait en plus aux blancs de s'en
prendre directement pions g4 pas mal
joué on va voir il reste 23 secondes
donc ce sera la dernière partie en cinq
plus un parti vraiment importante je
pense que les partis comme ça avant la
mi temps
celui qui peut marquer un but là peut
prendre un ascendant psychologique peut
pas tout de suite revenir et la prise f3
prix f3 il touche le cavale mais voilà
les blancs qui recule et peut-être que
ces quatre epr en b 6
est possible injouable pour aller se
venger sur le pion b6 est laissée aux
noirs des faiblesses à 5 c 6 6 il fait
tout reprendre 6 il prend ce pion tour
qui reprend des quatre d'accord émanant
lecavalier peut-être qui peut repartir
vers f1 ou trois noms il part en eux
quatre ils vivent peut-être la casse des
six avoir peut-être qu'il y ait des six
cavaliers avec 5
difficile à dire cap position qui est
compliqué mais on voit toujours wesley
qui domine à la pendule artemiev qui a
plus que 50 secondes contre 2 minutes 05
c'est vrai que le joueur américain me
semble un peu au dessus de son
adversaire
en tout cas dans le rythme dans cette
cadence mais on sait que le joueur russe
a toujours perdu en 5 + 1 et pourtant il
se qualifie il passe les tours il
arriver en demies en éliminant un joueur
comme great choc qui a été comme le
rappelait vlad hier double champion
triple champion même du monde de blitz
donc un sacré client
il avait éliminé sur un gros score il
avait fait je crois plus 6 plus est donc
il va falloir quand même être très
méfiant côté côtes américains risquent
quelque 6 échecs ci est jouable sur wais
y aura une jolie parlante de maths que
je vous montre en vitesse parce que ça
va jouer donc cavalier six échecs joué
il a pris acte 6 prix à six tours 6
et maintenant peut-être tour des six
pardon tous réussissent pour essayer de
voilà c'est chose faite d'échangés et de
s'en prendre aux pions au pion à jc g4
et envoyait la majorité avec un roi qui
pourraient être faibles plus que 20
secondes côte artemiev le temps qui
s'égrène peut-être qu'il ya du fou g6
ici jouable à voir et surtour des cinq
peut-être fou et 8 à muret tour c'est ça
qui peut tout couvrir
peut-être tour 5 du coût mais il ya tour
des 5 pour le moment les noirs qui
semble tenir au refuge et six tours des
cinq ça va être jouée quasi
immédiatement
non il prend un peu son temps peut-être
un coup comme tout recette ici pour
menacer haye ne serait pas vraiment fou
à vii qui aurait droit à une fuite
encore c'est tendu c'est serré b3 3e set
joué fouilles huit tours c5 probablement
fougue quatre tours c5 aussi c'est pas
facile de s'en prendre aux pions h5
la position est compliqué compliqué
difficile fouet quatre tours ces cinq
noms il prend son temps il réfléchit
encore artemiev il le joue finalement
tour g63 f7 tourache 6 alors est ce qui
venant ça marcherait pas de toute façon
ils menacent pas grand chose
peut-être un coup comme f3 puis on
prélève 3 ou fou prend f3 mais il y aura
encore droit g6 pour venir couvrir ou
est ce les qui réussit pas pour le
moment à percer la forteresse le kremlin
russe le kremlin tient le tan tient pour
pour le joueur pour le joueur sibérien
il va sûrement faire rager 6 attention
il en train de perdre du temps faut
quand même enchaîné les coups côté côté
russe tout rachat suite
est ce que est ce qu'un tour ces trois
tours c'est arrivé un jour où h3 il va
revenir en c5 fouet quatre échecs roi
mon entourage c'est 3 bougez peut-être
g4 maintenant pour essayer de percer
quand il fait tout rage 6 il va refaire
tout rage sept tours g6 et peut-être
tour g5 maintenant ah oui tour g5 ça
peut être intéressant pour pour proposer
les changes des tours et joué avec le
fou qui va être très fort les échanges
qui vont se passer mais les blancs vont
avoir un problème a pris rouages 5,3 g 7
et on ne peut pas monter attention ne
pas faire ces captures airwatch au la
faute énorme
oh là là là là quelle erreur ok l'erreur
maintenant il ya g6 fou et 5 fu et 6 ob
c'est gravissime sarwar wade s'est tu te
mets sur cases noires ya personne qui
rentre mais quelle erreur de la part du
joueur sibérien incroyable incroyable
simplement roi g7 et les blancs ne ne
peuvent pas passer un et les blancs ne
peuvent pas passer et les blancs alors
après ça joue il ya encore le roi qui
revient vers le pion peut-être que ça
gagne
mais les serrois h6 avec j'ai ici c'est
le fou qui vient fallait là il a même
fait roi g8 fouache cet échec et g6 g7
g8 voient c'est une erreur quand même
alors il aura perdu l'aller les quelques
parties qu'il a perdu en a deux en tout
cas il ya une pièce donnée en un dans
une position complètement égal avec deux
minutes à la pendule et artemiev la cac
a pris le temps qui a fait ses 4,3 g 7
c'est pas un mystique c'est il a peu de
temps à la pendule et il a craqué donc
artemiev qui se retrouve mené de deux
points sur sur deux erreurs deux erreurs
de sa part de grosses fautes et wesley
qui ramasse et qui mène 6-4 après la
première la première cadence ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va voir
un petit 6 minutes de pause qu'on va se
prendre maintenant tranquillement et on
va se retrouver et on va se retrouver on
va se retrouver
bah juste après la pause quoi alors faut
quand même que je vous trouve comment
comment mettre de la pub parce qu'ils
ont ils ont changé le n'oubliez pas de
defaud la chaîne si vous êtes nouveau
ils m'ont changé le truc de pub
bon je passe des pubs comme je peux à
tout les mecs
[Musique]
à
alors les mecs je suis de retour en
direct du coup
donc donc donc on va repartir avec le
match pas qui est favori d'après vous
chers lecteurs vous allez tambours et
j'aimerais bien mais qui changent la
musique mais bon c'est pas évident les
mini clip de droit moi je vois peut-être
un truc plus lounge ou quoi non je parle
presque pas très important
donc il rejoue une un début du fou j'ai
envie d'appeler ça comme ça on va à
nouveau avoir une position similaire à
celle qu'on avait eu un an il fait fou
des deux je crois qu'avoir fait il avait
joué avec ses 3 donc il a joué food et
de il a un petit peu modifié prisé de
prise des 2 à 5 à 3,1 gamer rock
je vois un truc s'ils veulent faudrait
une nouvelle chanson bonsoir alwil fait
des échecs qui part à deux fous j'ai 4 3
et rock qui va arriver à reprendre de la
dame et il va faire peut-être grand
roque plutôt à effet petit rock
il veut je vais avoir joué sur le x 2
qui va contrôler la case f7 contre le
cavalier mais bon il va falloir
peut-être faire rage suit bêtement et f5
plus tard en cas de besoin voire ouais
j'suis tf6
en cas vraiment de gros besoins et ça
devrait aller tranquillement
donc d'après vous est-ce que donc on a
un peu parlé avec le chat qui va qui va
remporter le match d'après vous est-ce
que arte mais elle va réussir un nouveau
come back ou contre eux wesley so
finalement il va il va trouver son
maître
à voir
avoir tout tout est possible en venir je
pense que vlad vague et dans les bus
lady nombre de cadres est il et il a
l'air dangereux en bullet après sow
avait été solide contre contre nac à
mesa sega qui pensent qu artemiev est
trop tendre si leur pic qui pensent qu
artemiev ça changerait oui enveloppe
peut en cacher un autre j'ai envie de
dire qu elle n 4 ou qui que ce soit et
quasi sûr de gagner
non non je n'irai pas jusque là moi je
donnerai on va dire allez 80% pour sow
et 20% pour artemis mais cela sera
encore un bon vent pour 20% pour
artemiev l'écart n'est pas si grand
encore
et donc ça peut ça peut ça peut revenir
quoi alors ils pensent haut et plus fort
et juste enfin oui plus fort juste que
jusqu'à maintenant il a été plus fort ça
c'est sûr mais ce qui va et ce qui va
l'être dans les cadences à venir on va
voir en tout cas pour le moment début de
3 + 1 il continue à jouer plus vite que
son adversaire et ça c'est quand même un
vrai signe c'est quand même un vrai si
ni continue à dominer en terme de
vitesse juste récupérer le le chat
youtube aussi on en est là pas de quelle
est la prochaine étape pourrait me dl
mais pour le moment c'est la finale du
grand duché pour demain adam g iii et
tourbe est un qui va arriver
les tours be1 pour s'en prendre aux
pions de 545 d'un match 2 on s'en
prendre à fortement pion aux 5 avec
c'est vrai le x 2 que je trouve très
bien placé côté blanc et vous passez le
grand duché sur le grand duché source
joue à londres autour bessin qui contre
attaque b2 donc après 35 va probablement
prendre en b2 il touche le fou fou prend
f7 et l'idée c'est que sur trois points
f7 sur price est c'est quoi l'idée tour
7 d'accord attaque la dame et dames
procès à tours procès trois prendre cet
état me 5 quoi c'est joli ça avec la
tour qui reste sans prise en b2 ils sont
forts 1 les joueurs et surtout reprend
f7 tour huit cavaliers prend huit tours
8 dames f8 il va sûrement faire ça prisa
fuite pris la fuite
et là il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas d'échec qui permettent de
gagner la tour y'a même pas d'échec du
tour donc wesley qui devrait s'en sortir
la tour prend f7 mais il n'avait pas vu
le foot - fc atteint il avait pas vu du
tout et d'ailleurs il fait froid à sweet
way alors pourquoi pas c'est carrément
une autre option de jeu qui est loin
d'être idiote aussi puisqu'il à quoi il
a un pion - ici mais ils menacent pas
tout reprend f7 parce que j'ai toujours
tours 8
trente secondes pour artemiev fou
pranger six tours prend ces deux il faut
f5
ok ils préparent chose qui les phares
d'un match 4 mais il prépare c'est pas
ils menacent ils menacent pas grand
chose mais en fait le truc c'est que le
roi noir il est complètement au bois dam
des cats la tour qui va peut-être venir
en cette e-menace maths en 1 déjà la
dame un nom qui peuvent peut-être
pouvoir naviguer ans et cette attention
il a pu en f2 emprise donc en f3 on
protège tous et manon protège ça tout
est protégé en fait là ils attaquent
rien la tour est protégée
il faut prend 1,7 sur cavaliers prince
est sûrement faire tout reprend droit
prend tout recettes et il doit y avoir
un math tour j'ai cette dame h5 et dont
il fait tour c1 alors tour c'est un
hymne à cela tout re 1 prise prise droit
là est maintenant prise en h7
et c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas d'échec sur
cette diagonale incroyable sow qui a
défendu sa non je sais pas s'il va s'en
tirer mais il était complètement foutu
il peut peut-être faire dame cinq dames
g7 et tout couvrir forces us ou moins
les changes des dames pas je préfère
quand même les blancs parce que avec un
cavalier défendre compte trois pions ce
pas évident mais ouais non mais il peut
prendre à trois il sacrifiera lecavalier
compte deux pions est fondamentalement
fous qu'ils prennent et qu'il annule
saint laurent en blitz assez loin d'être
évident mais bon c'est quand même wesley
so il va réussir à placer gens mais ça
va aller en fait là déjà il coupe bien
le roi ni menace tour j'ai trois échecs
sur g ça mais il va prendre à attention
prix g5y à tour ici donc qui peut pas
vraiment encore le faire bouffer kg 3
leur objet de recul et un an et menace
de mannheim et à tour j'ai trois tours
pranger ci soit lille a réussi à lui
placé il passait une petite île va faire
touré fisc a réagi ski épreuve 7 là il
va il va pas se priver ans il va la
tenter
il va pas se priver wesley
delajoux et même pour gagner au final
aux incroyables
oh la la la gaffe had a hi la ilaha illa
il après mou et bien écoutez c'est 1.1.1
rendu parce que là ça va gagner avec le
pion h
incroyable ah ça c'est terrible c'est
terrible ce prêt move terrifiant g8 3g
5e 6 rouaroua f8 et y aurait eu un arrêt
incroyable ça les amis le pré move c'est
incroyable ce même pas une arnaque à la
cwa ce les kiss mais a essayé de la
jouer pour gagner et qui et qui fait un
cadeau un qui fait un cadeau énorme
énorme
il a il a voulu jouer tempo pour mettre
artemiev en difficulté au temps et voilà
il a fait n'importe quoi et il a fait
n'importe quoi
pré move ouais freymuth bête en fait un
hymen au score il a il a pas il n'a pas
à tenter le diable et le diable se cache
dans les détails mais les détails c'est
des prix en pleine gueule parler quel
dommage quel dommage pour wesley après
pour l'intérêt du match c'est plutôt
bien mais c'est toujours un petit peu
triste entre guillemets de voir les
joueurs perdent des partis comme ça
prenne ou un petit peu un petit peu
spécial eu besoin de chaque nuit c'est
la scks that's right
c'est là c'est la sela est ce vrai nom
c'est vraiment la s
du coup pas pour aubert est ce là mais
pour mai pour la d'islam artemiev bon
alors cette position a cité une
sicilienne formation de pions chez venin
et qu'on n'en parle souvent quand on
suit magnus attaques allaient droit pour
les blancs attaque à l'el dame pour les
noirs c'est du grand classique qu'est et
qui vient on sait si c'est peut-être un
coup comme fouet si si
si les joueurs voilà il est joué on joue
le thématique sur la colonne g sur qui
on prend qui on prend et dames g7 matt
évidemment ce ne sera pas jouée par par
le joueur sibérien et sur pions
préemption pranger 6
c'est trop la catastrophe adac les noirs
vont pas toucher à ce fou et les blancs
voire peut-être l'idée de faire cavalier
quatre cavaliers h5 pour venir taper là
où le bla bla bla où le bât blesse
d'ailleurs un coup comme f4 peut être
une option ici avec l'idée de faire f 5
puis prend 7 puis ferrer 6 pour vraiment
foncer sur f 4 puis on prend du cavalier
et venir s'en prendre à ce fou c'est une
manière de jouer
la prius est pris aux sept prix des six
il a il a joué il a joué la comptabilité
mois l'arrivée échangeant des 8es et
sortir le fouet jouer le pion de plus
mais bon le pion plus il est devant le
roi ça pas être évident damned
car il menace rien dire une bonne chose
pour le joueur sibérien maintenant il
faut réussir à ramener les pièces en jeu
peut-être les cavaliers vers des 4 d'où
ils pourraient faire quelque chose
scholes à ce jour chez bonne
infrastructure chez veunac
c'est quand on dit sicilia notamment à
georges tu mets le pion réussissent et
obtient cette structure la face à ça ou
comme ça il a fait carolis ici justement
pour mettre le cavalier en d4 très
logique hein une belle case et sa
couperet un peu la connexion ça
forcerait peut-être les échanges avec
d'éventuelles découvertes intéressant
pour le moment parti qui tient toutes
ses promesses
il prend des huit prend des huîtres ou
des trois est ce qu'on essaye de faire
plutôt dams et 5 et à 5 et 6 4 pour
avoir le cavalier mvl ou est ce qu'on
met le cavalier en d4 pour taper f3
éventuellement même rebondir vers b5 et
jouer pour du cavalier c3i la fed à mme
bessis cigare plus ou moins les deux
options
est ce que j'ai commandé des livres des
chèques pour noël au nom là d'échec
c'est un peu le dernier truc que je
commanderai pour noël puis de façon
manuelle plus personne ne me fait de
cadeaux je suis maintenant c'est moi le
vieux c'est moi qui fait des cadeaux
maintenant c'est moi le tonton annonce
et tonton qu'elle fait des cadeaux quoi
je suis passé de l'autre côté du manche
les mecs je suis passé du côté du manche
où c'est toi c'est toi c'est toi qui
fais les cadeaux c'est bien tu vas tu es
je suis un ton tournoi elle est quoi
bienvenue chez les grands et ouais c'est
rilov
bienvenue dans le monde des d'aaron les
darons du game fait plaisir après 1
ça fait plaisir aux racistes et six sur
dame f6 dam des quatre et ils couvrent à
car au lieu de bien jouer sur d'amman où
il menace damas fils dame g7
et ouais mais sur dame m6 tu fais quoi
tonton basse et la question prix ces
deux procès de roy est fluide d'alger
cette dame proche c'est vrai c'est chaud
c'est chaud donc avalé f4 j'aime bien ce
qui s'en prend à eux six sur pion à 2 3
1 tout bêtement et a aussi sans l'air
ouais mais si je prends aussi sai
pranger 6 ha et sur alger achète à huit
c'est joli à ces jolies dames imparable
acebo dame imparable bien jouer wesley
qui après son erreur se remet doute sur
ses pattes
tel un chat qui retombe toujours sur ses
pattes et gagne la partie juste derrière
voyons si je prenais un autographe de 24
ans un autographe de double of ages et
environnement soyons sérieux
soyons sérieux ouais kg si c'était joli
trésor dans un ruck le précepteur bank
la question sur l'avenir des échecs
je pense pas que c'était très très
à-propos dans la dans l'interview avec
le précepteur une larsens ouverture à je
sais pas j'appellerais ça réty mais on
peut appeler ça une larsen je sais pas
comment s'appellent les double enquête
toi qui paraît plus à un récit mais j'en
sais rien tu as les noms d'ouverture
c'est pas trop ma spécialité
en même temps ça sert un peu à rien de
connaître les noms tu as donc au bout
dans mon coin il est bon de certains
trucs mais pas toutes les ouvertures
donc moi j'appelle ça un double enquête
aurait mois quand ceux ci si quelqu'un
vous s'agit le conte avec les blanches
fait un double enquête au tu as
quelqu'un je joue ça c'est comme ça que
la paix l'ouverture cavaliers ces six
prises prise écrit ces trois là
peut-être faire un petit tour c'est un
pour toucher le fou une première fois le
fou bougé après allait prendre en d5
essayé d' un peu liquidés sur des cinq
en encaissant g7 genre une variante que
je regardais dans ma tête
tu as c'est un peu ça tu as dans
l'esprit je me sentais très heureux et
ça c'est mieux pour les blancs c'est
clair donc tout ça un tour c'est 8 et
peut-être y va quand même essayer de
rentrer là dedans
une ruine à une nourrice faudra voir les
cavaliers en e2 et des deux spas henry's
ça existe ouest indienne à hawaï ça
existe bien sûr les stars viennent vont
être syrienne de l'autre côté donc
prises avec 6 prises avec 6 prises des 5
il reprend la dame peut-être voir jouer
sur un cloud ajoute quelque chose un
truc c'est que dès qu'ils bougent le fou
il ya le cavalier c3 en l'air mais il
peut alors 4e cavalier est touché ici
caisse à des ventes un peu compliqué car
il ya eu quatre tours c'est un tu peux
pas parce que c'est sûr échec donc dame
bouge prise prise et le pion dessin qui
est clouée sur qui on prend des 5.4 j'ai
pas des dames 17 qui rôdent je menace
l'âge menace là et je menace ça donc du
ku'damm prend prise prise prise qu'elle
et blanc sont beaucoup mieux ses pions
de plus quand même quand tu encore
différemment
et à 6 cas au lycée set peut-être pour
protéger le pion wef idée de chasse qui
retransmet le championnat d'europe
le championnat d'europe féminin grand
prix fit pardon féminin pas championnat
d'europe désolée surtout en europe ce
week-end ouais c'est pas une condition
très très regardé après avant nous on a
décidé comme d'hab' comme on peut pas
faire les commentaires officiels on a
décidé de pas ne pas se mettre sur cet
event ont fait pas trop les événements
féminin puisqu'il ya déjà tellement des
maîtres d'événements mixte où les
fidèles peuvent participer parce que
c'est pas c'est pas excluant comme comme
événement mais du coup on a décidé de ne
pas faire les événements les événements
femmes pour le moment peut-être un jour
mais pour le moment en tout cas c'est
pas un objectif
quand la première cette vidéo payante ce
que tu as tué par les sur un premier
répertoire bah écoute j'attends fable
pour le faire donc c'est moins dépendant
de ma volonté
ce que ça j'ai un peu fraîches pour y
faire sa seule mais bon c'est cool ça
permet de faire un peu des trucs à faire
d un peu des trucs à fab aussi donc
c'est bien je vous comme fabas pas pas
encore pu prendre de temps pour le faire
ça prend du retard a du retard pas
vraiment puisqu'il a pas non plus de
calendrier quoi on va dire ça se fait
moins vite que on l'aurait souhaité y'a
pas de commentaires en français pour cet
événement une grille nick même ça joue à
monaco bon après je peux comprendre vu
que c'est un événement qui est déjà pas
très regardée en anglais faire des
commentaires en plus en français c'est
peut-être un peu un peu too much quoi
fera quand une partie hommes femmes par
exemple fabre trois des candidats bas
difficile un difficile peut-être dans
une cinquantaine d'années 40 ou 50 ans
sera faisable
donc la position qui est clairement
illégal les joueurs tam tour compte dam
tour c'est normal en tout se fait moins
vite qu'on voudrait ouais mais bien sûr
est voudrais pouvoir tout faire plus
vite mais a le temps le temps et pas
compressibles sa suite rage et cette
dame c3 il va tout est changé
il va quand même jouer la finale et 15
pions - ou pas il peut peut-être faire à
quatre appareils fans qui au niveau
aujourd'hui gustavin personnes un côté
côté femmes
yako nehru qui joue pas mal quand même
sa rentrée dans un quatre contre trois
mois c'est qu'il va réussir à faire nul
c nul théorie 15,4 contre 3 après pour
un joueur de mon niveau par exemple sera
très difficile à réaliser face à un
adversaire de premier plan
mais là ce niveau là il va il va y
arriver
ban et elephant il va y arriver
way we fans pas au niveau pour les
candidats bien sûr mais peut-être
qu'elle aurait pu arriver après la
privilégier ses études et c'est un choix
que je respecte complètement je respecte
le choix de willy fans
je trouve même au contraire que c'est
bien à verser a les capacités de faire
des grosses études et cetera
tu as un peu les échecs à l'ancienne du
fait pas que des échecs
enfin en faites pas je respecte vraiment
très profondément en fait je respecte
même plus en fait quelqu'un qui fait ses
études à fond et même qui quitte un peu
les échecs et qui joua tu vas qui joue
amateurs moins à 26 50 27 je respecte
vraiment énormément fait parce que du
coup les échecs reste un jeu et les
échecs c'est un jeu donc je trouve que
c'est bien en fait de faire ça je trouve
que c'est sain tu as déjà étudié le 4
ps3 aux échecs
est ce que la question est sérieuse de
holden cash flow ou pas
je crois que j'ai quand même pas très
fort mais non mais c'est bien fait
hurler mais comment ils s'élargissent
l'esprit font d'autres choses dans leur
vie et où je trouve ça éminemment
éminemment respectable voilà l'essai de
tourner when we qui a repris ses études
aussi ouais je trouve çà et là il va
réussir à à tourner mais maintenant rage
et 2,3 et maintenant il va y vas
zigzaguer avec le roi il va encaisser f2
avec la tour la mandriva frère du
tai-chi way ouvrages et 5 3 et 3 6 3 non
qu'est ce qui fait donc comme il veut il
va mettre le ronde et 627 ils vont
encaisser f2 il va revenir avec le roi
et wesley qui va gagner le 4 contre 3
bien jouer wesley way salle à mon avis
elle fait mal un pur pour pouvoir tenir
qui aura pas plu du tout profité de la
gaffe de de wesley bien joué en
franchement non c'est pas du tout une
position fille d'orgue du stac très bien
joué très très bien joué on se fait plus
3 ça fait plus froid on est quasiment à
la moitié du 3 minutes
ouais si s'ils attaquent les bus est à +
3 + 4 je vois pas comment artérielle
pourrait remonter
[ __ ] il chie dans la colle puis cyril
objets oui j'ai mis du temps à
comprendre la blague
non sérieusement ça parle pas de me
faire cette blague allez allez pas ça
l'était pas elle n'était pas elle
n'était pas homologuée cyril of autant
retenta des blagues parfois qu'ils sont
vraiment bien autant celle là elle passe
pas la barre je demande la va pourvoir
sur la blague de cyril off est acceptée
non non c'est une blague qui passe pas
vla qui passe pas si rilov je trouve
qu'au niveau un matin ils prennent trop
au sérieux ouais ouais mais tout à fait
à golden cash flow je suis d'accord avec
toi bon là faut quand même qu'ils
serrent les dents serre les dents là de
fait des nuls remets toi parce que sinon
ça va parler du tout laval cyril a été
refusé après visionnage des images
les arbitres sont allés ils ont bien
regardé comme il faut et ils ont décidé
non je ne je ne me drogue pas cette
blague refusé bon
on membres cette partie qui continue
faut aux trois essais de s'en prendre
aux cahiers des quatre peut-être recul
et peut-être tour à des 1 tu laisses le
fou en d3 tu fais tour des inquiets
prend des trois prises des 3 es tu mets
la pression sur sur des 4 ha ouais mais
la gaffe adao la gaffe de wesley bas
j'avais pas vu non plus grosse gaffe
grosse gaffe dont de qualité très bien
joué de la part de la retenir
du coup et là c'est qualité net de plus
non il ya quand même un pur avec dame e4
précédure un devoir toutes les tactiques
dans un match comme ça sert et intense
vous l'avez vu notamment hier dans le
match avec maxime ya quand même eu
beaucoup d'erreurs
beaucoup d'erreurs j'espère que ce soit
pas trop creuser car il ya du suspense
en bullet balla écoute c'est quand même
plutôt parti pour pour ainsi berriane
elephant qui reviendrait à deux points
mais étant qu'il a deux trois points les
bullet ça va être serré
quatre points ça va être trop mais là
ouais c'est rien faire j'ai quatre mais
il faut qu'ils réussissent à se
consolider ainsi fait cai c3 fbk
peut-être tour eux deux
fou des deux époux ses trois arrêts
pourquoi pas faut réussir à se
consolider à pas laisser rentrer mais
c'est dur ils essaient de créer un petit
quelque chose avec ses pions quand même
un peu quelque chose que j'essaie de
rentrer de roi mais à vrai dire il ya
tour d un gars qui va arriver peut-être
car nf2 tu couvres il couvre la colonne
des avec les pièces mineurs tu reviens
villes alentours des 1 est mon tour eux
deux vraiment il joue bien on essaie il
a three entraîner
mais son adversaire veut faire tourner
un est rentré par derrière donc
ficarelli f2 et maintenant il veut fou
prend est rentré tubes en soit les deux
cramique favoriser le dynamisme des
échecs à haut niveau et stupide c'est le
premier mot qui me vient à l'esprit en
pensant à l'idée de cramique g63 bouge
ça tu vas mettre le quart ayant g3 pour
couvrir et remonte avec le roi comme ça
ils disent kramnik en gros c'est
d'interdire le rock c'est à dire de
revenir 500 ans avant je pense qu'on l'a
vu hier les gens qu est-ce qui kiffent
seller rapide donc pour qu'ils aient
moins nul et que je sois plus dynamiques
peut-être plus de parties rapides
peut-être une solution les gens aiment
il ya plus de public les joueurs m
bon c'est pas mon livre venir 500 ans
avant qu'il n'y ait pas de rock palmarès
j'ai augmenté ma taxe carbone de folie
en faisant tourner à alpha 0 pendant des
jours pour analyser mon truc inutile
pour un truc façon qui arrivera jamais
bon là et on revient et on range étroit
ouest et qui a craqué s'arrange pas
quelques nuls justement alors oui mon
les deux premières années toi - nul et
puis après tu aurais de deux nouveaux
temps nul coiffard mon nom c'est
vraiment l'idée de merde en fait un
mais bon le rock avait été justement
fait pour accélérer les parties parce
que les mecs galéré à mettre le roi en
rock
non c'est vraiment la fausse bonne idée
cieux mais bon ah tiens une troupe ce
qui est intéressant ce qui va jouer sur
u 6 à u fait quelle idée de quand même
les fourrages cathy va jouer avec eux
trois fous des 3 et 4
pourquoi papa t'es galles défaite parce
que tortue géniale le problème des
échecs ce qui est ennuyeux dans les
échecs c'est pas les nuls c'est que ce
soit trop long en fait ce qui fait chier
les gens aux échecs c'est pas qu'ils
allument match se finisse par un partout
comme au foot au foot ça dérange
personne qui est des nuls aux échecs non
plus ce qui gêne les gens aux échecs
c'est que les partis insipide dure au
minimum deux heures alors ça c'est pour
les plus courtes un serment la partie où
il s'est rien passé ou tu savais qu'il y
aurait nul après 15 minutes et a aussi
un pad partie insipide qui dure cinq six
heures où tu as eu une demi-heure
intéressante où il y avait un peu de
suspense et puis tu as eu quatre heures
et demie en fin août en fait tu te fais
chier en gros donc ce que le public
n'aime pas ce qui est pénible aux échecs
c'est pas les nuls c'est que ce soit
trop long mais du coup on fait en fait
cramique tu as heureusement qu'il est
pas médecins savent que si cramique
était médecin tu arrives avec un ongle
incarné cramique temps put la jambe quoi
sert-il fait le diagnostic bon il vaut
mieux couper la jambe on sait jamais
donc là si tu veux tu es sur un médecin
deux catégories attention hein tu
arrives tu à une crise cardiaque le mec
te refais une couronne au dans quoi sais
tu vois c'est un peu spécial c'est c'est
vraiment le mec qui a pas
qui a pas vraiment posé le diagnostic ce
qui comprend pas le monde dans lequel il
vit qui l'entourent et là on en retourne
un petit peu quand même au sujet de
willy fans c'est également intéressant
de s'élargir l'esprit et de faire autre
chose que des échecs dans sa vie
peut-être aussi de tuer alors un peu vu
le monde extérieur qui t'entourent ça
peut être aussi son intérêt quand tu
veux parler de sujets un peu plus large
on ne sait pas mais mais c'est vrai que
là le truc du rock
enfin surtout que c'est un retour en
arrière c'est une règle qui existait
déjà mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu avec
américain snc de plus intéressant quand
le quand la cadence accélérée mais bon
ça faudrait-il encore avoir de
l'empathie pour pouvoir comprendre ce
que les gens aiment mais c'est quand
même très spécial c'est un truc de rock
il ya de ça et j'ai pas lu les serveurs
c'était quoi du coup j'ai pas regardé
parce qu'il en a fini tu as well ma du
championnat du monde ni tu as a man
c'était c'est carrément une anti pub
pour les échecs quoi faire peur qui a dû
3 800 coup max par tournoi areva c'est
du troll c'est du troll c'est parce
qu'ils pensent pareil si ça mais fort et
que je lise
en page 3 du tout bon je vais lire je
regarde en direct alléno faig jolie
julie en direct la radio ser peur c'est
de le trouver sur le téléphone pendant
la partie les blancs semblent non je
suis pas qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est
mieux alors attendez
à naninne annan a mené wec espagne et
déjà c'est pas idiot ce que dit c'est
harper que du coup il change les règles
et du comtat prend les les échecs tout
un tas de parti qui n'existe plus bon ça
c'est pas faux na na na na hey parle des
pendules mon accord les points de vue
ont été introduits en 83 ça je savais
d'ailleurs
tandis qu il te dit souad manifesta qui
modifient de mouffe constrained si elle
m'a posé un droïde chute apple ni ok mon
il va interdire les nulle part sur get
him to complete de tournament
ok mais bon pourquoi pas
ok je te limiter le nombre de kwh n
enlève en face n'importe quoi
non mais c'est n'importe quoi ok c'est
ridicule sont ni des solides et
complètement ridicule limité à 800 coups
dans les tournois et du coup il tu es
obligé d'abandonner parce que tu n'as
pas assez de coups dans les banques et
enfin moi je propose une autre règle
c'est que c'est que c'est qu'à un moment
donné tu as un mec qui vient avec une
batte et si si tu pars parce que tu as
peur qui te mettre un coup sur la tête
bon vas tu as perdu la partie
et en fait donc celui qui reste et qui
est le plus courageux bon il risque sa
vie parce qu'il se peut se faire
assassiner en pleine partie
mais d'un autre côté il aurait gagné la
partie face yeux je fais des idées à la
con on peut en trouver plein enfin la
lumière au bout d'un moment c'est
maintenant c'est ridicule son idée
ridicule
l'avantagé c'est que ça verra jamais le
jour mais je pense que c'est du troll ou
le mec est d'être devenu complètement
fou j'en sais rien mais il n'y a
personne qui a eu l'idée de raccourcir
les cadences en fait ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on valide et la
plus évidente pour n'importe le
n'importe lesquels du commun des mortels
qui josé chaque amateur mans et qui
kiffent un peu les échecs comme ça de
côté
il n'y a aucun joueur professionnel qui
est capable d'or cette idée ça montre un
peu aussi lors des connexions avec le
monde et qu'en fait il faillit pas
failli retourner comme au 19ème siècle
qu'ils soient payés à l'audience quoi
comme on en parlait l'autre jour avec
vlad donc à oui tu as deux mille
personnes qui regardent
on va prendre 10 centimes par personne
pour la pub par jour vers 1000 euros de
priver m
donc effectivement way juste raccourcir
les cadences en fait c'est le truc assez
simple pendant les pros sont
complètement ouf
après on a aussi le deuxième problème et
c'est pour ça que ça arrive pas c'est
qu'il ya aucun sponsor aux échecs c'est
que du mécénat et ça ça crée un vrai
problème on en a déjà parlé maintes et
maintes fois ensemble donc les blancs
qui veulent droit qu'à trois ici et sur
f5 yves aux cavaliers cette cave 5 7 6 2
et il y avait une obligation de
résultats qui avaient des sponsors qui
mettait du vrai argent sur la table
j'avais un vrai intérêt financier
derrière ça règlerait le problème tout
seul ça joue pas spécial heures ma
limitera donc ça doit faire annuler
cette histoire quand même ce que
lecavalier loin du pion après la fugue
n'a pas pris direct c'était bizarre wab
et 5 mg 5 c'est bien joué dans sa grille
pour les noirs
donc ouais le cavalier c'est pas sûr
qu'ils tiennent ou pas conques le pion h
il a beaucoup de mal à il a un temps de
retard
et là c'est fini
l'échec contre échec et enfin il fait un
échec et jan pauwels et qui reprend
trois points
m'enfin je comprends à quel est votre
problème avec juste raccourcir les
cadences en fait sans chercher à changer
les règles en fait c'est juste on change
pas les règles ont fait 20 me + 10
secondes par coup en fin de vie une
bêtise ou 15 minutes + 10 secondes
vingt minutes plus 5 secondes ou dix
secondes comme vous les ont fait match
aller-retour en cas de nul on raccourcit
deux nuls ont raccourci et voilà le
projet qui perd éliminé c'est tout quoi
il est fini ou alors on garde les mêmes
règles et puis personne regarde on s'en
fout aussi tu vois mais en fait je
comprends pas c'est la solution elle
existe à l'ena turballe jeu ils gardent
les mêmes règles et aussi ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le niveau de jeu
aujourd'hui avec une cadence de vin plus
dit souvent plus 15 serait bien plus
élevé que le niveau de jeu il ya 40 ans
partie longue avec un loser bracket
évidemment si rilov
évidemment on est bien d'accord on est
bien d'accord
donc pour toi leur proposera que ses
cordes ans tous fait juste tous
apprennent davis qu'on va plus trouvé
l'idée l'idée vrai des échecs a battu
fait tourner alpha 0 sur vraiment savoir
la vérité
il joue 700 points elo au dessus de
carlson gamin donc au bout d'un moment
donc tu as est plus intéressant au
regard des partis par correspondance
aussi les mecs sont beaucoup plus forts
mais quoi qu'il est parti ils sont
intéressants à un niveau master oui mais
ces amateurs veulent continuer à jouer
en longues qui jouent en une phrase pas
le problème là on parle pour les
compétitions professionnelles dont
commissions professionnelles le circuit
principal serait en rapide après ça veut
pas dire qu'il ya une abolition des
parties longues
c'est pas parce qu'on a un qui prend le
dessus que l'autre n'existe plus
j'espère que ce serait les parties
longues serait le leu leu un circuit
parallèle il pourrait très bien avoir
encore des toits en partie longue phase
a interdit pas le truc juste dire que
les trucs létourneau il ya le plus de
financer où il ya le plus de sponsors ce
serait les parcs rapide parce qu'il ya
plus de public c'est assez logique en
fait ce que les gens préfèrent après si
on reprend l'argument de bien jouer moi
je propose qu'on donne trois mois par
joueurs par partie avec autorisation de
l'ordinateur pour tout le monde et au
moins on aurait des belles parties de
haut niveau et voilà ce serait très bien
on peut aussi faire sa com répond change
les règles on y voit là vous avez vous
avez trois mois pour jouer vous avez le
droit d'avoir tous les ordinateurs que
vous voulez toute la technologie que
vous voulez et vous nous produisent et
des belles parties et ça c'est vraiment
des vrais échecs et en fait les parties
en deux heures chaos comme il joue
maintenant c'est vraiment des parties de
merde parce que les joueurs jouent
vraiment très mal on peut on pourrait
faire cet argument là tu as faim
pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas trois heures s'est pas
assez il nous faut en trois mois ou
trois ans peut-être pas reparti pour
être vraiment sur quoi oui je rejoue
bien et voilà tu tues ferait tourner des
ordinateurs quantiques de google pour
lutter partie d'échecs et eu tord y ait
enfin un vrai niveau quoi je sais pas si
raide après mon argument est très
logique et la majorité des gens le
suivent enfin l'écrasante majorité mais
pas les gens qui décident donc c'est sur
le même problème mais non mais c'est
vrai que ce serait beau quoi il y aurait
des défaites par des heurts entre
fantastique et wind et merci à des
rafiots pour que ça venait de twitch
prime penser un petit peu éloigné du
match mais bon
donc peut-être un truc marrant sur cas
réaliste et si c'est la tête indique
marc ans qui sait si ce qui est logique
pour réussir le clou en gt2 qui prend
ses six d'impro 3 qui apprend aux 7,3 et
fuite qui est france et 8 se marrant ça
mais je repars avec le cavalier bon mais
la cyberhaine elephant qui se fait qui
se fait découper un j'ai envie de te
dire cyberhaine éléphants tu n'as plus
de défense
les défenses de l'éléphant son sont
mortes 1 là elle a un pion de moins et
il peut et peut-être espérer un peu sur
les fous de couleurs opposées mais il
reste les cavales et le fou en plus
s'ils touchent la case bessette way dans
la c4
du coup le cas il va devoir repartir en
b 8 on va pouvoir faire jouer le roi ou
alors ils filent les pions hockey est ce
qu il a le temps accueilli ces quatre
aya 4 way et qui avait lieu 3 à 3,3 m
non c'est mort ça va faire deux pions
moi et c'est mort et donc ça fait plus 4
maintenant pour wesley
donc su pu le faire effectivement les
parties rapides
comment se fait-il qu'ils ne soient pas
déjà c'est toi qui attire le plus de son
format le problème c'est qu'il ya pas
vraiment de sponsors c'est du mécénat
unico vraiment j'avais déjà parlé plein
de fois et le problème du mécénat et ses
terrasses et que comme il ya aucune
obligation de résultat en fait c'est
toujours les mêmes gens qui décident
qu'il n'y a pas forcément de résultats à
la clé bah du coup les choses peuvent ne
pas changer c'est comme si tu as une
entreprise et qu'elle peut perdre de
l'argent de manière indéfinie un infini
en fait genre tous les ans elle te
présente un bilan négatif elle perd de
l'argent mais en fait elle a de l'argent
illimitée donc elle peut continuer
continuez continuez continuez continuez
continuez continuez en fait rien ne sera
jamais changée par titre est possible
d'optimiser le truc pour que ça marche
et que ce soit intéressant voilà c'est
un peu pareil avec les échecs en fait
comme n'y a jamais eu d'obligation de
résultat bat le truc évolue pas quand on
se complaît dans un truc qui marche pas
en gros pour faire simple si vers
elephant et dans le permafrost là ces
fortes fauré qui se transforment en
cyber mammouth en fait là l'éléphant ne
suffit plus
ces 6 ouais mais granger source et du
mécénat aussi mais ouais il ya des
rapides et tout ça mais bon il y aurait
peut-être des choses à changer en
commençant par parler de choses à
changer
déjà faire des formats de coupe pour le
grande chaise tour et a fortiori ça
marche pas vraiment leur truc non plus
mais parce que pour que ça marche il
faudrait que ça vienne de la fidh plus
que du grand duché ce tour et en
plusieurs formats est vraiment pourri
tout au long de l'année
c'est un tournoi en toute ronde ça dure
six jours c'est n'importe quoi leur
format puis tu vois même quand il commet
en tout cas y'a pas grand monde sur leur
truc c'est pas c'est pas fait de manière
jeunes et friendly pour pour le grand
public mais déjà sur tout le truc de
l'année il faudrait que ce soit un
système coupe ça c'est sûr bref avec ce
soit un peu un peu plus jeune et
dynamique way
bon il va défendre
bref suite il va ramener le roi berek
accueille séville qui a aidé 6 bien joué
très bien joué dans cette structure deux
pions vous avez une structure carlsbad
le carré demander si c'est fantastique
ouais il ya beaucoup plus de monde sur
vellave sur les langues officielles web
assez grave même pas c'est qu'il ya un
problème à un moment donné c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible avec
quelques petits pas est quelque chose
qui est mal fait c'est presque pas de
face-à-face a toujours le cas mais mons
et je me dis c'est impossible en fait
t'as pas les images tu étais pas
référencé machin tu peux pas avoir plus
de monde c'est impossible
normalement c'est impossible bon mais
elle a du coup ça va être égal il n'y a
pas qu'elle prend à quel point b 5 fu
prend mais qu'elle prend des quatre vous
prélève saturne 3 preuve ça te prend des
quatre qui fasse gaffe quand même fait
tour à 8 pourquoi pas je pouvais pas
prendre bêtement en d4 mais bon
ok prend des cinq puis on prend prises
sept et il va ramener le roi ans et si
le bon ça va être nul 1-1 qui juge que
tu es bon tu te crées dans la communauté
fr enfin c'est la référence des échecs
français
ouais bah du coup vous êtes tu prends
une référence des chèques français pour
commenter le truc vous pour avoir des
idées pour pour améliorer les
retransmissions tu vois par exemple des
idées quoi par mois ça me paraîtrait
logique si j'avais une entreprise et que
j'avais un mec qui était hyper compétent
compétent pour faire un taf je me dirais
je vais le prendre par exemple tu vois
après comme je faisais moi ça me touche
plus du tout quoi juste on parlait de ça
moi je m'en fous complètement maintenant
ça mais c'est pas ça qui va me faire
plus avancé au moins avancés mais mais
en gros en gros faut réussir à faire les
bons formats les bons trucs mais
pas qu'une question de comment termine
loin de là c'est plus profond comme
problème mais là le format pour londres
pour la peine il est pas mal avec les
demi-finales des finales il y aurait pas
les deux parties rapides au début il y
aurait les deux parties longue durée que
les rapides
ce serait sur le week end genre samedi
dimanche voire même vendredi samedi
dimanche lors une demie vendredi l'autre
demie samedi et la finale dimanche
franchement ça aurait une super gueule
bon la finale elle est nulle ans et
enfin c'est plutôt les noirs qui presse
quand même dans le sens où ils ont un
pion pas s'éloigner ça peut être plus
sympa à jouer mais bon ça peut pas
gagner
y'a pas y'a pas de plus en plus c'est
une finale deux tours
prévoyez qui a peut-être envie des six
trous un plan pour presser un peu ours
et 4g après peut-être joué avec des
quatre machin normand il a fait nul
façon ça va rien ça va me presser pour
wesley
il reste deux parties en trois plus
ainsi s'il peut maintenir l'écart à
quatre points je pense qu'il sera
content
donc
fourbe et 4 you were passé le fou
probablement par la ba ouai c'est
exactement ce qu'il est en train de
faire partie des favoris pour le double
de bullet de mon art luxe ouais ils les
îles les 1 kg 3 s'en prend au four
qu avec fougue et h7 peut-être joué
trois dames d2 et peut-être même s'en
prendre avec du fou prend ainsi ses
cavaliers h5 qui pourrait arriver tout
cas une bonne position côté côtes
américains wayne dans le joueur
américain qui est quand même plus fort
ouais non calvitie s'il veut casser le
centre pour ça qu'il a ramené le fou ans
et 7
ce sera plus intéressant de l'avoir ici
pour contrôler le 5 et la diagonale des
fous des deux et peut-être tour deux
tours un qui va arriver pour contrôler
la colonne pourquoi pas il a joué que
huit seraient qui l'empêchent cavaliers
h5 petit pétard damev cette tour f8 ou
dame g6 pour changer les dames mettent
le cavalier angers 6 peut-être et et
jouer pour un coup comme cinq ans vous
comme cavalier f4
donc intéressant intéressant pour le
joueur américain pour le joueur sibérien
part donc à relief 8 d'accor tour 8 dont
qui blindent bien le pion et dames g6
maintenant d'accord donc il va échanger
ouais ça peut faire plus en une
transposition et les questions c'est ce
que les noirs vont bien défendre le pion
peut-être réussir à jouer 5 à un moment
je pense que ça va tout à fait pour les
noirs ça m'a l'air très correct pour
pour artemiev cette histoire tour 8es à
cavalier h2k là je sais pour jouer
cavalier g4
probablement mais c'est vrai qu'il y
aura jamais de f4 alors est ce qu'il ya
une autre idée caché qui m'échappe la
jetée g4 sa part chasser la gouaille
chasse un peu la tour et fils est ce que
c'est un intérêt je suis patient de
cavaliers avec 400kg 4 carrillo a
peut-être khz et h5 même tout proche du
roi prend à jouer et touche la tour et
maintenant est ce qui peut faire j'ai
quatre ou même tête j'ai trois
cavalières 4 qui est des trois cavaliers
5 voilà j'ai essayé de le faire arriver
à eux cinq cavaliers et en plus il va
passer par f4 il va faire mal quand il
va passer en f4 lecavalier ce qui va
taper ici est prêt pour partir par là
bas est allé jouer pour ces 5 5 est
maintenant f4f g5 f4 j'allais vous le
dire et maintenant alors tout re 5 ce
que c'est une option qui j'ai six tours
ont aussi semé a peut-être f4 en l'air à
la fin à roye g2 3g si tu vas faire j'ai
quatre puis on prend et tous rêvent de
kayes pro f4 qui va arriver assez bien
joué
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont bons ou tour eiffe
un verre ou wave 3 way wild 3 merouane
3,7 et tu peux pas prendre ce cas cavani
g6
peut-être qu'il a joint un peu vite aïe
c'est raté touré fin c'était exactement
la même idée mais pas ce problème
touré singles qu'est ce qu'il a comme
idée maintenant oued et 4 hockey bas 5
dont il va échanger mais des qui part
avec la tohu y aura cavalli g6 la cia
package et cissé qui a tout réussi ce
voyou c'est raté avec 3,3 kg 5
il s'est planté il s'est un peu planté
et il s il s assit périon elephant le
loisir peut-être de la jouer il a quand
même un pion de plus avec les noirs
maintenant il reste quoi il reste trois
vins il reste trois vins dans la cadence
donc normalement il y aura encore une
partie derrière c'est à retenir gagne
celle là il revient à trois points et
c'est vrai qu'ils relancent un peu le
suspense on va voir on va voir si vous
êtes nouveau n'hésitez pas à mettre un
petit mot dans le chat un vous êtes bien
entendu les bienvenus
n'hésitez pas à poser les questions qui
vous turlupine sur les échecs
faut il suivre la chaîne si vous le
souhaitez c'est pas encore le cas et
donc il va rester une partie dans la
cadence papier nouveau guide je suis
nouveau et je comprends rien
tu sais pas jouer aux échecs par contre
là ça va être difficile celle-ci merci
pour les commentaires c'est un plaisir
c'est la première fois du coup de télé
des lights et refait il refait son truc
avec kaka et c 3 pouces et 4.4 d'un
match 5 qui a été si cela me prend 1,5
non il recule le fou hiver fouet cette
âme 5 rocks
ils ont un temps pour un pari de jeu
demande monsieur dasa ouais il joue 90
mi temps 5 + 1 60 83 +1 et 38 ans un
plus à la main cet été quatre peut-être
dans quelques années des 5
je m'étais arrêté de trois fois mais là
je suis depuis trente-huit son switch et
d'anglais donc tu kiffes faut il suivre
aussi ma chaîne perso il ya un lien
juste en dessous pour le dire la même
nous voulons c'est de comprendre en
écoutant en regardant mode autodictate
mais c'est dur faut que vous essayez les
parties pédagogique sûr sur youtube je
pense à quelqu'un qui peut être un lien
des dernières pour les joueurs débutants
ça peut carrément vous aider il
rassemble un peu mieux pour les blancs
dans le sens où les pièces blanches sont
plus avancés sur l'échiquier on voit
qu'elles ont un peu plus d'idées et
qu'elles sont mieux développer on a
juste plus en jeu donc les noirs vont
devoir faire un peu une technique
d'élastiques quoi c'est le 3 puis ça en
ce moment
ces mines sa cigarette ou comprendre
parfois rêve à 1507 en mal de galères
encore jusqu à 2740 tu galères après tu
rentres dans un niveau intéressant
qu'avec une question des cornées tu les
lieux où tu les connais genre front tu
lâches fouet f3 jeu mais au moins trois
autres que les cadences rico n'est quand
même pas quand même merde quand même ça
c'est facile
m quand tu fais ça toute la journée les
gars se les voir s'en prend aux sens et
j'aime bien les blancs enfin chaque
année qui sont bien placés il ya quatre
points d'écart à défaut qui gagne là le
joueur russe
qu'at il dit si c'est tentant mais bon
ça suffit peut-être pas ça suffit
peut-être pas parce que c'est jouer les
yeux fermés ou ibo dior
c'est assez simple enfin simple faire
une partie c'est simple bien jouer une
partie c'est autre chose
pourquoi deux autres cas mais un gars
qui jouent aux échecs schygulla les deux
gars que tu vois sur les caméras en
dessous c'est les gars qui jouent le
gars qui sue c'est moi je commente
simplement
les cases on les retient qu'un peu
d'entraînement et à force de dire les
coordonnées on les retient les cases toi
aussi tu les connais jean françois
jacques
mais du coup le plus isolé ça avance ou
pas trahi soit 3600 spectateurs sont ni
ans mourait c'est la première page mais
winner prennent truc c'est comme ça
marche bien et que les gens restent sur
le stream
les premières pages sont plus
qualitative après par un moment
ouais j'suis d'accord augusta qu'on les
avait plus de passer un bon moment que
que d'essayer d'avoir tous les coups et
où sa fin moi je suis repenser ça en
fait quand les gens disent ouais je
regarde un commentaire des chèques pour
progresser aux échecs je dis toujours
voir en fait tu veux progresser aux
échecs faut pas regarder des
commentaires faut travailler c'est bien
après de regarder les parties de haut
niveau et tout ça te fait une culture
mais de base quand tu regardes est parti
c'est surtout pour t'amuser
donc on essaye surtout de faire la main
de maître la bonne vague de la bonne
ambiance et puis à puis si on peut
lâcher quelques petites infos c'est
intéressant mais tu vas pas commenter
pour pour apprendre à jouer aux échecs
sinon tu fais un cours un cours d'échecs
fin tu abandonnes je suis prof c'est mon
métier mais mais bon c'est quand même
deux choses complètement différentes
quoi c'est comme si tu regardes et
roland garros pour progresser au tennis
tu vois je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
meilleur moyen
bon bah ouais je sais pas comment il a
fait un fait un tour de magie mais le
pion des cas très mal le pion h3 et mal
et il va celui ci bien parti pour faire
plus saint caprais à retenir qui peut
peut-être proposer nul et voici va
peut-être accepter ou st peut-être joué
la sécurité puisqu'il ya quand même un
grand avantage dans le match on connaît
moins ses gestionnaires lui-même dans le
neuf cent soixante contre magnus y avait
un petit peu géré il avait eu raison il
a raison il al'avantage mais après +5 je
pense que ce sera déjà plus 4 pour les
bullet ça me semble rédhibitoire mais +5
je vois pas dans quel monde en plus il
joue plus vite ça wesley qui semble
quand même vraiment être au dessus et
donc il va il y aurait de nouveau en
finale
ouais on highway ce lait chaud et tout à
fait j'ai même envie de dire wes leixoes
h au w ils sont connus les mecs ouais
c'est des mecs du top 10 mondial plus ou
moins au wex top 10 est là on regarde
les demi finales d'une compétition et
demain il y aura la finale d'une autre
compétition très forte avec la le numéro
un français numéro quatre mondial contre
le numéro 3 mondial le joueur français
hier maxime vachier lagrave a éliminé le
champion du monde des demi-finales du
grand duché ce tour qui a un gros
circuit professionnel tous âges suite
c'est quoi les chances de sow contre mac
en finale voire l'année dernière où on
voyait on lui donnait aucune chance mais
il a fait un gros match à hauts risques
cette année il est encore plus fort et
il a un petit 30 35% possible il ya des
cages pride important aussi le
prestigieux lan on l'a peut-être un
cashprize je sais plus exactement pour
ce tournoi là mais peut-être le gagnant
il prend 10 15000 dollars donc c'est pas
un très gros cash price
en revanche pour le grand duché pour
demain je crois que c'est 125 mille noms
125 mille dollars
donc voilà ça ça comment cet ancrage
plus intéressant
165 mille huit cent cinquante mille cent
cinquante mille alors j'ai pu les
chiffres en tête je crois que c'est 125
assez joli il ya cavaliers des quatre au
prochain et la tour étant fermés bon là
c'est un peu la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase sibérien lalo va devoir
se transforme en glace +5 pour wesley
c'est quand même j'avais dit plus de +3
c'était chaud avantage ou est ce les
mais il pouvait revenir +4 je mettais un
ouais c'est vraiment bien devant la + 5
ça me paraît quand même il va y avoir
quoi il va y avoir un 9/10 partie il
faut qu'ils gagnent 8 2 face à 7,2 ça me
paraît compliqué salut paquito fimo
est-ce que par les carreaux à participer
à ce tournoi va on verra l'autre
demi-finale mardi pu me salua de chasse
roquettes donc on va faire une une
nouvelle petite pause
moi je vous posais judith poser des
questions à faire une nouvelle petite
pause avant le dernier segment
demain la frontière nouvelle dingli
rennes demain ils affrontent ding
à partir de 17h bon du coup on va se
faire une dernière petite pause juste en
train de vérifier que tout aille bien et
on se retrouvera
du coup dans six petites minutes pour
pour le dénouement du match
me françois serrés sommes très curieux
quels lots c'est dur à dire du cas
francs du cas fera mais peut-être mille
quatre cent mille cinq cents voilà une
petite pause s'impose j'ai envie de dire
à de suite les mecs
[Musique]
alors les mecs je crois que ça va
repartir
donc le score c'est 12 à cette grosse
domination doit ses sauts dans ce match
qui laisse pas une miette artemiev il a
vraiment dominé en cinq plus un son
étreinte s'est resserré lorsqu'il est
passé à la cadence de trois plus un
manant ça on va l'en but l'été à cinq
points d'écart le match me semble pliée
mise à part explorant à voir si si les
défenses sibérien peut gagner les deux
premières on va dire
il pourrait se relancer dans le match
après s'il y arrive pas c'est que ça
sera mort est faux parce que y'a quoi ya
neuf partis dits partie en gros on va
dire à 10 ouais il faut il faut vraiment
il faut il faut vraiment qu'ils
attaquent fort quoi faut vraiment qu'ils
attaquent fort on va dire que fo qui
gagne 8,3 aller jusqu'à 8,3 ça va donc
si west et en gagne 4 c'est fini
d'office il en gagne 3 c'est chaud lance
pas trop ce qui se passe c'est peut-être
du bugue k-way ces gars très tranquille
le mammouth ce profil web on va on va
voir ce qu'ils vont en bullet 1 à l'esa
est reparti dont 30 minutes de bullet à
partir de maintenant qui ce lensois eux
quatre ces cinq cavaliers 3 à 6 ans qui
continue à jouer cette sicilienne à 6
quai paquet pas super bien réputé ouest
et qui prend le centre qui refait un
étau de ma roxy les taux de maroc 6 et
la refermer sur ces tarnais tôt ils vont
empêcher b5 et des 5 mai le fou en g2
déjà vu ça dans ce match dames deux
prises prises maintenant il va jouer les
cases noires dams est peut-être va jouer
roi h1 f4f 4 direct
gk doigts pour envoyer g5 h6 jouer h4 il
joue de manière très pratique hein c'est
du bullet a donc on en voit il prend
prend peut-être un petit coup comme g6
maintenant pour toucher le pion au sisqa
relief 6 il le défend enfin il le défend
il pourra reprendre de toute façon et f4
donc wesley qui joue de manière très
entreprenante qui prend les devants qui
prend le sens très rapidement
artemiev qui pourrait prendre angers 6
et prendre en d4 ne veut pas dédoubler
les pions il fait grand roque donc on
s'attend à ce que vous restez maître la
tour en b1 pour s'en prendre option b 6
il a récupéré le pion mais maintenant il
va y avoir des 5 fu et 3 et le pion b6
les cases noires vont être en difficulté
on voit que les noirs n'ont plus de fous
de cases noires justement et wesley
semble semble le mieux dans cette partie
tout cas il semble avoir une excellente
position foot roi fou prend des 6 arrive
le roi blanc et très bien défendue par
le fou la dame réussit pas naviguer
c'est un avantage aussi à la pendule
côté américain outre le cavaly qui va
revenir vers ses 5 est maintenant
peut-être un coup comme dame b2 pour
venir finir la pression il a fait cinq
prises et tour c1 il veut vraiment venir
sans prendre peut-être avec du tour pro
b 6
alors ça échangeant ces cinq des six est
maintenant il va pouvoir prendre en
bessette sur échec et le fou va être
monstrueux puisqu'il va d'un côté
défendre alors il commence par dams et 4
et de l'autre côté attaqué d'un missile
en fou prend b cet échec crois c'est
cette force et tout reprend ses 5 qui
arrivait et suroît b 8 pouces et 6 on
gagne la dame et ça fait six points
d'écart maintenant le seul petit petite
chose qui peut rassurer artemiev c'est
qu'ils ont joué que deux minutes
donc ça veut dire quoi plutôt enfin on
serait plutôt sur un ripou eurydice pons
partie mais bon il a quand même perdu
quoi donc plus si c'est le joueur
américain qui se dirige vraiment vert
vers une démonstration aussi les sauts
qui m'a l'air d'être encore plus fort
que l'an dernier ça pourrait donner une
très très très belle finale contre
hikaru ils sont vraiment ils sont
vraiment forts ouest et sow qui avait
éliminé au tour précédent ben maxime
vachier lagrave ni plus ni moins maxime
qui a lui éliminé hier dans un autre
tournoi magnus carlsen wesley qui a
gagné le championnat du monde de 960 et
qui est bon qui est bon tout au long de
l'année saf en partie classique sauf là
où ça compte le plus mais mais sinon
c'est c'est vraiment un boss des sceaux
elle va vraiment vraiment impressionnant
vraiment incroyable précis non
franchement
franchement je kiffe je kiffe le wesley
qui est en train de voir aujourd'hui et
on ne peut que quatre heureux s'il va en
finale
si on aurait voulu avoir un peu plus de
suspense mais quand un joueur joue à ce
niveau là quand il à ce niveau de
précision
on ne peut que s'incliner un petit peu
comme magnus hier devant maxime qui a
reconnu après sur twitter à la
supériorité du joueur français
que pouvait-il faire d'autre si ce n'est
acquis et c'est la fessée qu'il venait
de prendre de la part du joueur français
là encore la position doit et cela avec
les noirs semblent plus qu'intéressante
il ya un quatre contre trois de ce côté
là qui pour le moment est un peu moche
et et de l'autre côté et de l'autre côté
ça va ça va attaquer ça va envoyer du f4
à tout moment et ça va venir envoyée il
ya du foie justice aussi qui peut rodez
il ya du h5n1 il réussit à se dédoubler
les pions mais au final il va devoir
jouer une finale assez désagréable avec
les blancs et là ils pourraient ils
pourraient passer du rau il est
déconnecté des connexia la déconnexion
allemand il est reconnecter les
reconnecter un petit problème de
connexion le le joueur le joueur
sibérien rien ne va car et lycéens pour
empêcher poussée de fou prend b3 mais il
en position foetale leroy peut-être
monter jusqu'en russie ça en je pensais
qu'il allait ramener en russie ce pour
protéger eux cinq ils montent en h7
on en est où on en est à 20 secondes
pour les blancs 37 pour les noirs
poussée de tour à tour d2 il va faire
tout re deux tours des huit ouais donc
il défend tout le fou qui vit en d1 pour
chasser la tour tour prend des deux
tours prend des deux avait amélioré le
fou et 2 qui restera en prise à la fin
oui donc là c'est complètement fini ça
fait une qualité net de plus le pion
sait qui est voué à être perdu à bajaur
tout reprendre de et tour ses huit au
prochain pour gagner ces cinq là il ya
tout qui tombe alors c'est bien joué
parce que surtout eu deux cas et prêt e
2 il va vouloir
sauvé le clan ils meilleurs atours des
deux peut-être tour ses huit cavaliers
des quatre bons il s'est un peu sauvé
mais maintenant il ya roy e 5 3 des 5 et
tour procès si ce qui arrive
les secondes s'égrènent pour le joueur
russe
d'accord il réussi à échanger un petit
peu mais la tour viande et 6 il couvre
tout et maintenant il veut roi gk3
pranger trois abandons et ça fait et ça
fait 7 points d'écart ou donc vous
disais qu'il fallait pour pour que le
match soit un petit peu serré à une
victoire rapide et quasiment direct de
artemiev pour recoller un petit peu là
on est passé de plus 5 à + 7 et bon
voilà ça va être la marche triomphale
maintenant de wesley la question c'est
un peu de savoir si on va rester aux
alentours de plus 5 + 6 pi 7 ou si on va
carrément aller chercher un +10 ouais
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment incroyable
est ce que je fais un live ce soir n'ont
pas d'autres live après est ce que je
montre faire les arénas prochainement
ballet vendredi john chess 54 mais le
truc c'est que les arénas il y en aura
plus en janvier février mars avril on va
avoir quatre mois sans arena ça va être
ça va être un petit peu frustrant
j'achète moins comme non il faut faire
des arénas mais bon la prod classique va
prendre le dessus
très agressive un bon du coup mais vous
pas d'aréna après demain arena ban
normalement oui
après il y aura le match 2 2 maxime
cohen qui aura priorité mais normalement
oui madame carillon f4s que edf
progressant lots oui oui mais elle
progresse beaucoup augusta quand ce
vraiment une grosse c'est une grosse
d'yves d'avoir un prof ça fait vraiment
une énorme différence par un bon prof
soyons précis mais oui c'est important
pas forcément bon parce que
parce que bon aux échecs ou l'importance
à un prof qui a vraiment qui
s'impliquent vraiment et qui a envie que
tu progresses pas quelqu'un qui s'en
fout plus ou moins
ouais après il ya quand quand tu étais
en première page quand tu as eu des
premières pages d'arc jojo il ya
toujours moins de monde sur le chat
qu'il n'y paraît donc cesser c'est pour
cette raison-là et puis en plus il ya
des il ya des live qui sont plus
lorillard il y avait beaucoup de monde
sur le tchat
il ya six cent soixante personnes hier
qui sont passés sur le chat j'ai regardé
donc lé jour il ya plus de gens sur qui
passe sur le chat suivant suivant les
événements là le match et pas très serré
les gens regarde ça d'un oeil
exactement et n'oubliez pas de foule au
la chaîne sa première fois que vous
suivez ma chaîne perso en lien en
dessous donc dans celle là est ce que le
siberia d' elephant va la gagner à wasyl
esquive à risque et roy f2 attend des
cas et des deux il va faire froid de
trois cavaliers eux quatre ces super
risque et ça fait 3 il va y avoir
d'ahmed deux échecs 3f quatre dames
pranger trois rois ou 3 il doit jouer la
gagne là de toute façon avec les noirs
ah non il prend là nul
ouais mais bon après il bâille considère
qu'il a un match perdu
sinon il aurait tenté la gamme puisque
sept points d'écart avec aussi peu de
temps à jouer tu es obligé de l'attenté
il reste 21 minutes payez pas mal de
parties et combien eu trois parties déjà
il est trois parties trois parties ouais
c'est ça il va y avoir dix parties dans
ce truc là est en arrêt il peut s'y dit
peut encore gagné 7-0 quoi pourra
redécouvrir fois il faut contacter un
prof ou en club a bêtement
plett mans donc cette partie c'est une
anti berlinoise et du coup ça ressemble
beaucoup à une italienne ou là à
tourcoing f7 et d'un projet 6 allez hop
ouais c'est ce qui s'est pris un cheapos
finalement voilà il peut qui promet
d'être l'hôte prendre h 4 ça m'a fait 3h
cette tour f1
ça semble très dangereux ce qui va ce
tour f 7 niché cinq tours f 7 kg cette
carrière
trois dames pro3 rouaix rimmel et il
peut plus revenir défendre hugo d'amours
3 c'est ridicule allez ça en face à en
faire une pour cyber yann elephant
mais puisque les il peut plus rien faire
dame ses ouvrages et 3 balles et ça en
faire une course iberian éléphants qui
va un petit peu revenir puisque jouant
au niveau des minimums pour prendre des
élèves non non pas spécialement
mais non pas spécialement
pas spécialement bien faire d'un projet
deux fois je crois alors est-ce qu'il va
essayer jour un peu faire tourner un peu
la pendule ouais bon il a raison de le
faire
il veut pas se fatiguer il va réussir à
faire la tournée la pendule à bonn une
bonne bonne minute s'il le veut non une
minute j'exagère un peu mais à 40 30 40
secondes
en tout cas une position complètement
futur il a une tour de moi il joue un
petit peu et voilà retenir f qui va
mettre le mat en place
et ouais c'est qu'il va attendre mais
bon il veut vraiment gagner le match
mais il a fait un peu halana k
il se laisse mater sur l'échiquier ça
fait toujours tourner la pendule oui
donc s'il a décidé sauf qu'il est ça
veut dire qu'ils respectent et qu'il a
peur d'artemis f1 quand même le fait
qu'il fasse ça mais ça veut dire s'ils
décident de faire ça je vois pas comment
artemiev pu récupérer six points mais ça
c'est un joueur qui l'inquiétait en
début de match il ferait pas ça s'il
était sûr à 100% de gagner contre max
linder il n'avait pas fait mais là et on
sait que artemiev est bon en bullet 3043
bien classés c'est par un fil rouge
jamais c'est quand même un bon joueur et
donc il va assécher quatre peut-être
l'autre cavaliers h4 cette fois ci donc
il veut assurer le coup comment sont
calculés point bas quand tu gagnes une
partie tu gagne des points
tu gagnes un point là dans le match tout
bêtement mais les points elo et si c'est
les points de classement
c'est une formule mathématique qui
calculent qu'ils calculent les points
par rapport au niveau de l'adversaire à
ton niveau combien de points tu gagnes
ou tu perds et ses points match 0,5 le
match nul je crois que si route jacques
s'installe en france joue pour le club
de chartres
mais ouais mais ça en est fan qui a des
petits problèmes de connexion plus normé
bon là il a vraiment tout outil marche à
l'envers pour effleurer sur foot est roi
et ligue b 4 ici j'imagine aux cavaliers
3g france3 fr et feu ait eu quatre
peut-être b3 vas y vas y vas prendre le
pion c4 comme on l'a dit si six joueurs
syberia ampère unis sera le match sera
mathématiquement fini à mais réussi à
faire ce petit chipeau la prison de cinq
prisons des cinq prises en b 5 prises
ici peu effective à prendre tout reprend
et tours 7
ouais ouais c'est bien joué parce que
t'as pas le temps de faire tour ces deux
avancées sur la deuxième il ya échec et
échanges
donc là il prend le pion à millas pas le
temps de ramener sept tours angers 3 bon
il ramène en j 1 du coup il va faire
tourner cette voie là ça va échanger ça
va faire nul et ça va faire une petit
nul mais ça permet assauts de d'avoir
fait encore tourner la pendule il reste
de moins en moins de temps dans le match
cette partie là il peut la faire durer
six ou est on va voir s'ils proposent
nul ou par ouais il propose nul et ça à
faire nul mais il va encore on va dire
que maintenant il a besoin d'une nul
pour s'assurer le match ouais c'est ça
six minutes car oui il reste à peu près
six partis six points d'écart comme ça
il ya une partie qui s'est jouée à un
peu vite donc s'il obtient encore une
nulle un peu longue comme ça le match
sera à mon avis complètement plier le
patron cm vers la grille contre 47 et où
il y avait
et oui hervé il s'est qualifié il a
éliminé magnus carlsen au terme d'un
match extraordinaire et je pèse mes mots
tu peut d'ailleurs voir le résumé qu'on
a qu'on a fait avec vlad de ce match
c'est en bêta tourner ça à 1h30 du matin
on est vraiment des fous on est vraiment
des malades parce que ça qu'il ya un
petit problème technique sur la vidéo
que ce qui ennuie à une vidéo qui est un
tout petit peu frisé à 5 minutes on
avait oublié d'éteindre stockfisch dans
nos analyses et du coup ça fait friser
le redis un moment donné mais on n'avait
pas le courage de à 2h15 du matin n'est
pas le courage de retourner 45 minutes
de vidéo ça va par interviews des verts
après le match mais peut-être sur le
live officiel je sais pas nous on fait
de l'artisanat l'un n'a pas on n'a pas
tout c'est toutes ces belles choses
voilà wesley qui regrette un pion en
plus c'est la force et les changes de
damas la cyberdéfense qui boit le calice
jusqu'à la lie quand on y z os les six
prenait encore une nulle c'était bon là
il joue de nouveau pour la gagne la
différence de niveau est trop grande et
politiques ayant nador everett a vu le
petit risio non c'était sympa on s mais
on voulait faire un truc de 20 à 25
minutes mais au final il y avait
tellement de partir voir que ça a pris
45 minutes là il montre le roi il va
faire tourbe et six tours bessin car mon
avis ait fait à 5 direct
on était un petit tour f 5 échecs
histoire de remettre l'orangé 2 et
envoyé le pion qu'il fait tour 5
pourquoi pas mais moi je serai bien b 5e
à chaque fois après
cinq façons il faut envoyer le pion
artemiev qui et truqueur c'est par
animer un peu le feu il s'est créé un
pion passé artemiev il s'est créé un
pion passé mais la fin est un échec mais
l'oeil mêleront aka 3b 3h pas trop
compris ce qu'il a fait avec cette
manoeuvre
du coup pour rester qui avancent de plus
en plus dangereusement et à parfaire ces
deux là est le gros problème c'est qu'il
peut faire froid d2 ce qu'il allait il
ay la sueur à vii il a eu six échecs et
tout reprend cas pour faire une dame
pourra g7 roi des 2 h 7 tours d83 fc3
pranger 4 détroit où il est bien avant
g5 des deux familles en avril et un
tempo avons comme quoi c'est compliqué
les finales mais c'est wesley qui
l'emportent et la partie celle là elle
aura duré très longtemps et donc il
reste plus que 12 minutes de match et
wesley qui repasse à +7 et web avril sur
la scandinave
il fallait la sortir direct si tu
voulais gagner artemiev il fallait la
sortir direct si je pensais jouer sur la
finale au maximum la lumière c'est pas
ce soir dans ces vendredi samedi
dimanche de riquier faut le savoir
bon bah du coup là le match est plié
est ce que vous pensez quoi s'il est est
ce que vous pensez qu un seul et pourra
pourra pourra déranger la casse si la
cave en finale quel est votre avis à
vous est ce qu'on aura une finale à sens
unique
enfin c'est un peu une question que je
vous pose qu'allez vous votre avis moi
j'ai le mien je voulais dit mais chacun
a son avis n'a qu'à intouchable dont il
vend c'est serré on verra ce qu'ils vont
faire juste une nulle dans celle là
franchement je comprends jamais à quoi
ça sert l'aller quand les matches son
pied je comprends jamais à quoi ça sert
de comptes de continuer à jouer donc
vous pensez que que n'a qu'à certains
pensent que naqaba va être va être bougé
qui va réussir à le faire vaciller
d'autres non on verra
ça fait neuf ans que ce soit et au
dessus en ce moment la kfor et je
supporte saut on n'a qu'à beaucoup trop
rapide avoir soit 15,5 me tuer en bullet
ce sera dangereux mais tu vois en bullet
on disait que que le que le cyber y on a
été dangereux et finalement et
finalement os et qu'il aura dominé quand
même assez facilement
on verra on verra
il va refaire dame projet 3 je paye
s'est mis dans le caca tout seul wesley
dans celle là il faut absolument pas
qu'ils échangent les dames faut faire
attention qu'il pouvait pas venir en h21
sinon il y aurait eu dame cinq échecs
braderie sur l'opposition qui voulait
avoir de toutes façons il n'y a plus
assez de temps et puis ça va jouer
longtemps
c'est complètement anecdotique c'est
bien joué il se crée un pion passé très
avancé ce qui est très important en
finale de dames et maintenant il va
falloir se cacher des échecs pour
pouvoir l'avancé perdra influence change
pas grand chose dans cette position là
on va voir un comment peut-être des deux
chais pas ça va jouer mais ça va être
gagnant le pion est bien trop avancé il
veut des deux maintenant qui revient
bien joué il défend quand même sacrément
bien wes les uns je peux vous dire que
ces finales là elles sont dures à
défendre et même si finit par la perdre
il aura défendu très longtemps peut-être
3d un sacha c'est le roi il est vraiment
vraiment vraiment bon en défense c'est
reprendre aussi longtemps à bloquer le
pion c'est vraiment un exploit
roy 20 à 30 fois même position eyes a
fini par se tromper il a fini par se
tromper os et en manque de temps mais il
aura joué très longtemps cette finale il
aura joué très longtemps il était
vraiment pas loin d'eux n'était vraiment
pas loin de là nul il a défendu pendant
une éternité et il a fait tourner la
pendule
donc reste deux parties peut-être 3,20
deux ou trois ça dépend mais dans tous
les cas il ya quoi il ya six points
d'écart oui mais c'est comme je vous ai
déjà dit plein de france et ce pitch est
moi je serais pour arrêter les matchs
direct ce soir est pourquoi pour pas
laisser les matchs jouer comme ça je
vois pas trop trop l'intérêt je trouve
que le match pourrait pourrait s'arrêter
là qu'on n'aurait pas perdu grand chose
honnêtement après avoir sur elle c'est
pas moi qui fais les règles c'est pas
moi qui fais les règles
ouais j'ai eu une petite pub par monde
en profitant
et lance pas le même tournoi aujourd'hui
à west équivalent à perdre ça là encore
un lecavalier à mon avis il va pas faire
long feu
il peut revenir à cinq points
il reviendra pas ouais c'est qu'ils sont
à la pendule il en a marre wesley s'il
en avait pas marre ils ne seraient pas
tourné comme ça et freecom compte maxime
il veut vraiment avoir un minimum deux
parties à jouer ça le soul il va se
faire mater au prochain il est écoeuré
il est écoeuré sur la caméra mais il
laisse tourner à fond
ces mecs qui a dû faire h quatre
prévenus déjà et ouais c'est qu'ils se
laissent tomber et c'est reparti donc là
il va rester il reste trois parties
encore cinq points d'écart 3 parties
puisque y voir une annonce pourrait y
jouer maintenant nous de jouer
maintenant et deux partis il y en a une
qui va repartir et
mais il en reste deux ça a du sens du
coup ce nom de partie variable sur la
durée des matchs à jouer la montre non
way parfois ça joue un peu les est la
montre à la fin mais bon après ça donne
un petit bonus à celui qui mène le match
je trouve que c'est pas plus mal
moi ce que je trouve dommage us et il
devrait y avoir un genre une charte en
fait il fait qu'un certain monette a
perdu le match et que ça continue pas
toujours ça dommage de voir ça c'est
déjà arrivé qu'on voit une demi-heure
une heure une heure et demie de match on
connaissait un résultat déjà des matchs
qui était plié une heure et demie avant
la fin la voilà les dernières vingt
minutes on reste est soit pris le plus
cette là qu'il a gagné à 15,8 de la fin
on aurait pu on aurait pu arrêter
pranger si ce n est pas mal joué parce
que sur cavaliers prend il est fou prend
f5 et fou pranger 6 alors ça va
peut-être être la dernière va peut-être
être la dernière salle à suivant wenzhou
est donc wesley qui mène dans la dans la
dans la section du let
nombreux on pourrait on pourra voir un
joueur aussi un joueur qui abandonne le
match pour pouvoir refuser de jouer à la
section bull est par exemple en dernière
partie du match
je vous rappelle qu'on aura rendez vous
donc demain c 17 heures samedi dimanche
18 10 15 heures donc 17 heures vendredi
samedi 15h dimanche 15h pour la grande
finale du grand duché ce tour 2010 9
avec maxime vachier lagrave numéro un
français qui vient d'éliminer le numéro
un mondial qui sera opposé à dingli
rennes numéro trois mondial joueurs
chinois et on verra si si le français
réussit à se débarrasser de son
adversaire ou pas donc dans cette partie
on va voir s'ils attaquent des blancs
est suffisante mais ça m'étonnerait
quoique beaucoup de pièces qui arrivent
sur le roi maintenant ça peut suffire
j'aime beaucoup de pièces sur le roi
elle est bien ensemble bien 4 et agisse
si ce qui va tomber et attaqué de toute
part ça va être dur à défendre ça pour
les noirs du coup il prend 1,4 et il se
débarrasse d'un problème mon le roi est
pas très bien il ya quoi ya un deux
trois quatre cinq contre quatre il ya un
pion pour cette poubelle
on y va peut-être à tenir son rang il
est bon en défense tout ce qu'on lui
souhaite
il aura quand même du mal en bullet
contre naka on va voir ça puis le match
là après cette partie là sera terminée
mais deux hommes veulent pas se faire de
cadeaux
je pensais qu'ils allaient faire kg 4
mai où il allait prendre les pions ça va
échanger
ça va échanger massivement ce que ça va
proposer nul non je vais jouer ça si ça
propose nul allez ça s'accepte et ça
finit bah ouais c'est qu'ils gagnent qui
gagne les trois cadence du fou gagne le
bullet gagne le blitz 5 + 1 et a gagné
le blitz e3 +1 donc wesley qui a été qui
a été grand et qui a réussi à remporter
le match donc prochain match the speech
et sera probablement mardi à 18h ou s
ils carmona camurat contre et car on n'a
qu'à mieux raconte requis contre
nepomniachi
et on verra on verra ce que ça donne à
mon avis n'a qu'à rien énorme favori
mais pour pour savoir ce qu'il en est il
faudra suivre ce mal si vous êtes
renouveau n'hésitez pas à follow à
mettre un petit follow sur la chaîne ça
fait toujours très très très plaisir le
petit le petit choeur petit coeur qui
bat et demain ce sera à 17 heures pour
la partie nv holding après demain samedi
et dimanche ce sera à 15 heures si vous
êtes nouveau donc le petit follow sur la
chaîne faut aussi en dessous voir un
lien vers liens vers les chaînes perso
de tout le monde notamment de moi même
une maxime vachier lagrave pas si vous
suivez vous aurez la petite notifs
demain si vous demandez les notifs quand
le match commencera
je vais envoyer un raid pour ceux qui
veulent voir les interviews vers la
chaîne principale duchess comme comme ça
vous aurez les interviews des joueurs
vers un peu ce que ce qu'en pense aux et
et vous pouvez aussi demain
éventuellement voix y aura normalement
l'aréna francophones qui débute à 20h30
pour ceux qui veulent savoir qui passe
il a été mis en place c'est pas moi qui
m'en occupe là en ce moment trop de
choses à faire à gauche à droite mais
mais je vous laisse je vous laisse
regarder ça pour la trouver et je vous
dis et je vous dis du coup paraît demain
quoi merci d'avoir suivi ciao ciao grand
merci à vous